Three,
two,
one
the great and powerful Pat Miller touch.
I don't know about that,
but you are.
Listen man,
I'm,
it's an honor to have you in here.
I've been watching your show for a long time and you're a contrarian thinker.
I love it.
And you've,
you've prompted a lot of people to think differently,
right?
Uh,
maybe it means,
I think information prompts people to think differently.
Well,
when they get pounded with us enough and hear it enough,
eventually it starts to sink in,
right?
Yeah,
I think so,
man.
And when you talk about,
um,
guys who have been around like you,
you are one of the real pioneers of MMA.
You know,
it's one of the reasons why I really wanted to have you in here.
I remember back when you were fighting,
I remember back when you fought Matt Hume and what was that like?
Extreme Strand.
Okay.
Yeah.
That was John Peretti's thing.
I mean,
dude,
you've been around,
you've been around.
You were the early days.
Bare knuckle.
Yeah.
No,
you know when the thing is,
I always tell people,
Dan Severn yeah,
we flock to withdraw who's 270 pounds at the time.
And he was still obviously pretty tough back then.
Still Pretty Mobile.
It was not a,
not a fun fight.
I can tell you carrying his weight around for 30 minutes,
but it was tough.
But Matthew human was the guy that made me realize that I wasn't a fighter yet
cause I was 15 and no,
I think I was ranked fourth in the world.
I fought Matt ragdolled him for basically the whole first round through him
around like a rag doll.
But he was just biding his time and wait.
And then they caught me with some knees and damaged my nose and the ref or the,
yeah,
the referee and the doctor stopped the fight because back then it was very
controversial.
They didn't want a guy with a crushed nose or whatever and so they stopped the
fight.
But I realized at that point he knew a lot more than I did.
He had.
That was an interesting fight because I totally disagree with that.
Stop it.
You know,
I was watching it.
I was like,
this is crazy.
How can you stop a fight for a broken nose?
Well,
and it was,
I got headbutted.
I used to spar with a lot of pro boxers and I got headbutted by a pro boxer and
he separated the cartilage from the bone.
So that gap is still there.
So that's what they felt.
My nose was bleeding a little bit,
but so that's why,
that's why they stopped it.
So,
but broken noses,
they're just,
it happens and it's not dangerous.
It's like maybe somebody saw those movies where you like,
like remembering a movie guy would hit the bottom of the guy's nose and drive
the bone up and it was like Mike Tyson talking about it,
right?
He did.
He didn't like these puts it,
puts it,
but the one up to the brain,
that might be the worst Mike Tyson impression ever heard.
I'm going to let that go though.
I'm doing my best.
Doing my best man back then.
Yeah.
Nobody really knew.
Like what was dangerous,
what wasn't dangerous.
It wasn't like,
oh,
a body of fights that we could draw upon.
And I was doing televised debates with politicians at the time.
We really to keep the sport legal in the state that I was scheduled to fight
him.
So think of how stressful it is to train for a fight,
stay healthy,
try and pay your bills,
do all the stuff you're doing.
And at the same time I'm debating politicians in that state who are trying to
pass a bill to ban the sport that I'm scheduled to fight in that state.
I'm panicking,
I'm freaking out.
So I do my homework and I'd get in debates like represented the Boleyn from
Illinois.
I got,
by the time we got done with the debate,
he goes all agree with Mr [inaudible].
He's obviously,
you know,
I think that they expected to go into a debate with a punch drunk box and by the
time the debate was done,
I crushed him.
And he's like,
well,
maybe if we could just do away with headbutts.
Yeah,
no,
that was his rebuttal at the end of it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I see how they think and I see that.
Dot.
But I think today,
even to this day,
I don't mind headbutts.
I don't either because you train for them.
If they're legal,
that's what you're training for.
And it's a legit technique.
Like why is it okay to slam your elbow into someone's face?
But it's not okay to slam your forehand into someone's face.
Right.
And it's very effective.
If a guy's tying you up in the guard and his head's right there,
you can do that and he can't really do it back to you.
It's an eye.
I mean,
I,
I watched when I was in my first no holds barred tournament in Chicago.
Oh God.
I don't even remember the name of it anymore.
It's been so long.
But um,
I saw a guy get headbutted 42 times in the first round and he ended up winning
with a triangle.
Why you ended up winning the fight?
It was Marcel loverage versus this guy named Johnson.
Mike Johnson,
I think his name was Marcel loverage ends up losing after crushing him with
headbutts.
Mike Johnson's in the shower,
they're running cold water on him,
trying to wake him back up and he collapses and they have to throw in an
alternate.
Wow.
But it was,
yeah.
Headbutts up,
obviously were legal then,
so,
wow.
Yeah.
Headbutts like nat was marked the hammer.
Coleman,
he's on the ground,
knees on the ground.
You see the head on the ground.
Yeah.
But I mean,
you think about when Coleman was in his prime,
he was all about headbutts and when he fought Maurice and he took more ease
down.
That was back in the days when headbutts were legal and Maury Smith,
he defended against all that doing all of this.
Yeah.
It's just another technique and,
but without that technique,
it's sort of like when I,
um,
one of the ones when I realized that taekwondo is very limited was when I
started working out with kickboxers and I started getting punched in the face
and I was like,
oh,
no.
But if I learned,
I've learned this,
you know,
thing that is only good if somebody doesn't punch you in the face.
Like,
this is terrible,
but you know,
you were an open thinker obviously,
and you realize that the thing was with early MMA,
everybody was so tied to their technique.
It's like being tied to a religion and refusing to see something else.
It was a lot of that.
So guys who are taekwondo experts,
wrestlers this,
that they were so,
so attached to their art that they refuse to learn anything else and they just
die because of it.
They get crushed because of it.
And I just early on when these guys are dumb asses,
why wouldn't you want to know how to do a lot of things?
You've got to have a big tool box,
but there was always a lot of pride in your art,
right?
There was always a lot of guys like wrestlers who were only in the wrestling or
kickboxers,
the only in the mortality just want to stand up.
They didn't want to go to the ground.
They just want to stand up and that that just costs you in the long run.
Especially when you see like a real complete,
like a guy
like mighty mouse,
like a guy like mighty mouse is at the top of the heap trained by Matt,
Matt Hume,
right?
Yeah,
right,
exactly.
And he can do everything.
Yeah.
I mean it doesn't matter if you're a wrestler,
it doesn't matter if you're a kickboxer,
you're fucked.
You're fucked everywhere with that guy.
And it's because he's got this just incredibly well rounded skill sets.
And I think the days of the specialist I think are still,
they're still kind of here.
I'm surprised with that still the case.
Yeah.
There's a few guys that can still pull it off,
but the guys that can pull it off or like the Damien Maya's or the wonder boys.
Yeah.
Like wonder boy,
it's just such an elite striker that is,
if he can keep the fight standing,
he can kind of work a lot of guys and because so many guys have not done karate
and things like that.
He's,
he's like a Rubik's cube.
They can't figure out.
Yeah.
Well he's long and that weird sideways stance with that front leg.
Those guys who have a good front leg like that karate style point fighting style
that they're used to blitzing in with that good front leg.
Very hard to gauge that distance.
So different.
Yeah.
I think Woodley did the best job of anybody in in fighting him and I think
that's like a roadmap for it because like people booed Woodley and gave Woodley
a lot of shit,
but look Woodley's the one who heard him in both fights.
Right.
And that that's the way you got to fight that guy.
You can't just charge after that guy you had the criticisms of Woodley in my
mind I think,
you know,
look,
it's a two man dance right when we kept as title.
Yeah.
Ultimately that's all that matters.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
If I'm the champ,
I'm just trying to keep my title.
I'm doing enough to when I'm not there to be the most exciting fight.
That was my mentality because I knew once you get,
cause I fought totally different before I got to the EOC.
I was just a psychopath and go out and just go a hundred miles an hour until the
guy was done.
Right.
But once you get in the UFC,
then that's okay,
we can cut you if you lose.
Right.
It's like,
okay,
now I gotta change the way I fight.
Well,
there's also the wind bonus.
I mean especially now,
did they have the wind bonus?
Yeah,
that's tagged to me is a real issue.
I think a guy should be paid what they get paid.
I think if you're,
you have a contract,
the contract for x amount of money,
if you have points on the paper view that's on top of that,
but the idea that your win or loss,
it could be in the hands of what we have deemed completely incompetent judges.
I see it every week,
every week.
And you do a lot of commentary yourself in these smaller shows.
I'd imagine.
Sometimes it's even worse.
I've,
I mean we've gotten in trouble to the point where we had people come to us and
go look the promoters at different Oregon that from different organizations when
there was really,
really bad decisions.
You know,
when I was working with Michael Chavela especially,
we were brutal on the athletic commissions and we'd hear about it and go,
you guys need to back back off.
I've heard it too.
I heard it from athletic commissions too,
but I'd say go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
there's guys in there that are fighting for their life.
They literally trained for months and months and some point,
someone who literally doesn't even understand martial arts is giving these guys
a decision,
a loss or a win.
And that's 50% of their money.
And that's crazy.
I remember the first time I witnessed it as far as a coach when my IFL team was
fighting in taxes.
We are fighting,
I think bosses team and I looked at the judges and all of them.
One of them had a uh,
a bouffant hairdo and old lady and then two old guys with white hair.
And I went back to the locker room and I go,
guys,
you can't let this go to the judges.
They're like one foot in the grave and the other on a banana peel.
They know nothing about what they're watching.
Like we are in deep shit.
If we can't do it well it's,
I think boxing is a very complicated art and I think it's a very difficult thing
to see to score,
but it's way more easy to score then martial arts.
Absolutely.
There's so much going on when a fight goes to the ground.
I mean,
I have a friend who,
a judge who literally said to me in the middle of a flight,
one of the female judges or referees rather,
uh,
judges,
one of female judges turned him and go,
what is he doing?
Like what is he doing now?
The guy was going for Kamora.
What is he doing?
Adelaide.
Adelaide Berg,
right?
Yeah.
We've,
we've heard you,
you talked about her during one of the UFC.
I mean carmia joking around with his lady.
Very nice lady.
Yeah.
But like I said,
my mom's a really nice lady too.
I wouldn't want to judge when a judge,
but I said the Adelaide bird before,
the pride in Las Vegas Lawler was fighting in that one.
Right.
And I thought,
I'm just going to ask.
And I walked up to her and I go,
excuse me,
I'm new to the sport.
Could you tell me what a triangle choke is?
And she looked at me and went,
oh,
walked away.
Yeah,
she's just [inaudible] maybe she's like,
this is a trap.
I fucking pat villages to try and trap guy with cauliflower ears asking me new
to this sport.
That's hilarious.
He probably had like a transparent grin,
like you couldn't hold it back.
You know those Grenz just it's,
it's sad that this goes,
it's awful.
They suspend fighters constantly,
but one are they going to start suspending referees and judges?
I think I've only seen it one time.
I agree.
I mean judges in,
in,
in for sure referees as well.
But I think that the,
the real thing that's so disappointing to me is that there's a wealth of martial
arts experts out there.
Like there's so many.
Yeah,
there's so many good coaches that would be great judges.
There's so many great x fighters.
There's so many people that are just really well versed in martial arts.
They'd be able to tell.
And I also think three people is a ridiculously small number.
I think for you you're,
you're like five judges.
Yeah,
like five judges would.
I think it makes sense.
It was a lot of the shitty decisions.
That's a good idea because if it's two and one and you like,
there's sometimes you get a split decision.
You're like,
what in the fuck?
Like one person saw this completely wrong and the other two guys got it right.
Thank God the other two guys were there.
Well,
if there's five people,
and this happens more than once,
you say,
okay,
we've got a weak link here.
Let's get rid of this person.
Right?
One judge will have it unanimous one way and the other judges will have it
unanimous the other.
It's like,
well,
how the heck they should be.
They should be held accountable.
They should.
Someone should have to sit down with them and say,
got to explain.
Like,
what are you seeing?
Like what's,
let's watch the round.
Sit Down with me
and tell me how you think this guy was getting the fuck beat out of him.
Was winning.
I just,
it's criminal dude seen,
screwed up.
It's just,
it's,
it's heartbreaking.
It's heartbreaking.
It literally is like stealing money from these kids,
you know?
I mean you're,
I just don't like the wind bonus,
man.
I just think it's a bad,
I don't think anybody fights harder for it.
See.
And I don't even,
I don't even necessarily subscribe to,
you know,
fight of the night and knock out of the night and stuff like that.
Yeah.
I don't,
I think they just bring back the yellow cards for stalling type stuff.
Right.
But how pride did it,
right.
I think that's a great way to do things.
And when pride did it,
what did they take 10% of your purse?
I think so.
And know,
and they would end up,
I mean,
you'd get dqued eventually,
right?
Yes.
We pull the red card and you're done.
Right.
If it was more than one yellow card,
you get DQ.
So they would give you a yellow card if they thought that you were either doing
something illegal or if style,
age of stalling or whatever.
I mean,
in college wrestling.
And they knew that they had to change things,
right?
They had to speed up the action and they started calling,
stalling a lot faster in college wrestling and it changed college wrestling guys
get after it.
Now you know,
my problem with it though is that there's referees at separate fighters when
they're working real hard against the cage.
And I think again,
it's guys who don't understand,
they don't understand how difficult it says when you have,
one guy was trying to take the other guy down,
the other guy is trying to defend their landing shots in between trying to open
up space and then the referee will say,
keep working.
I'm going to separate you guys get,
don't work.
Like what the fuck are you watching it?
They're battling their battles.
They literally don't understand the position.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's a giant problem.
And think about how many referees have never truly trained right?
A lot.
And if they did train,
it was a long fucking time ago.
A lot of the guys going in there with big fat guts.
And how many times have you called fights and all the years you've been calling
fights and been saying,
he's out,
stopped the fight,
stopped the fight.
I wonder if you're so close to it that you don't see it as well.
That's,
that's not an excuse.
It's an excuse because you know,
you've trained for so many years in martial arts,
right.
You know,
when somebody is unconscious from a choke,
you know,
when a joints getting destroyed,
you've been around it enough.
You've trained high level enough where you see it,
you know,
you can see their stomach where it's going in and out really hard.
You know,
they're unconscious,
right?
Where referees look at somebody in their eyes are wide open while his eyes are
open.
So we must be conscious Europe moron.
You don't understand,
right?
Yeah.
What do you have thoughts on?
Um,
forcing tap outs?
Like if a guy gets his arm broken,
like that's a controversial thing.
Like if stopping a fight,
what do you think about Tim Silvia and Frank Mir?
Yeah.
Tim got his forearms crazy one because in that one I kind of agree with her
because it wasn't an elbow,
it was the middle of the arm.
Both forearm bones went at the same time.
And so I didn't see that angle.
Right,
right.
Tim's back was to us in the corner and herb stops it and I,
and Tim gets up and he's like,
what the,
you know,
doing a great acting job,
right.
Tim,
you know,
for whatever reason was able to pull that off.
I mean,
that's not a pleasant feeling.
Obviously.
Your,
your arms snap in height and Tim gets up and he's like yelling at her.
I go in,
I start yelling at Herbert.
Herb's like Pat,
I swear to God,
his arm is broken.
He's pleased.
And then I see the replay on the big screen and I got her,
well,
I remember the crowd was booing and then we played the replay back and I'm like,
watch it,
watch it right here.
Slashing here.
But he'd go,
oh yeah.
And then I told him,
I go wave to the crowd when we walk out of the cage with your broken arm.
So Tim goes like,
ah.
And then we got back,
we got backstage and the doctor looked at it and I go,
how bad is that?
And he goes,
oh,
fucking arts.
Yes.
This hurts.
Yeah.
It was bad.
So the doctor that did the doctor then,
the doctor that did it was a good,
good friend of mine,
orthopedic Guy who I trained for many years.
He was a bull rider at one time and then became an orthopedic surgeon and then
trained with me and kickboxing.
Right.
Tough guy.
Tough,
tough,
tough dude from Texas with imagine.
And he goes,
I've never had to order plates for a tibia bone to replace to put some of these
foreign bones back together.
He goes,
there's big as the normal humans Tibia.
Oh yeah.
Tim's,
it just,
yeah,
it was,
his bones were massive.
He goes,
they don't even make,
I had to use Tibia plates.
Wow.
Yeah.
Healed 100%.
Cause there's a long time though,
right?
Like Dad,
dad really struggled with that.
That was,
I remember him saying thank you to herb dean for saving as career.
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
you know,
if he let him go on and that,
that thing got taken down.
Here it goes.
Once it breaks through the skin,
right.
That becomes a giant issue for infections.
All kinds of,
here it is right here.
Jamie pulled it up.
Frank Mir.
That mother fucker has broken more arms.
They're not showing it right here.
Oh,
it says was right on the cup is that may play.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's another thing about metal cups.
That's a weird little loophole.
Here it is.
That's a weird angle to look at.
That
Daddy,
that's a weird angle.
That was ugly.
It was ugly.
Those metal cups,
man,
that's a weird,
uh,
still loophole.
Like you could still wear those,
those tie cops steal.
You should be able to,
but you're kicking metal and it's also a crazy fulcrum.
If you got a guy in an arm bar that's,
you got to fucking metal rod there.
I like it though.
I like,
I'm sure you do.
But the thing with the old timers that taught me and k one and Muay Thai was you
take those metal cups and you take a sheet metal screws from the inside out and
you screw this,
put the sheet metal screws through and then back them back out.
So there's raised edges everywhere on it,
right?
So you wear that.
So if,
if they need you or kick you in the groin at shreds their meetup on their knee
or their foot.
Right.
So that's what the old tie fighters would do is that's the way they would do
their cups.
So that's how I started doing it.
So if they're going to low blow me,
they're going to shred the fricking leg up.
The problem with that is it also works if you get a guy and you mount them and
you drive that thing into his sternum,
then you've got like you're shoving into his sternum.
That seems like a weapon.
It seems a little bit,
it seems a little bit like little cheating.
We,
yeah,
I,
there was a couple of other guys that did that back in the day,
especially the Chicago circuit because I was fighting kickboxing and in Chicago
a lot was Chicago,
like a rougher circuit dude.
It was,
uh,
they would do k one rules Muay Thai and then I started in the PKC style
originally and I hated it because it was,
you know,
the light tree,
like the dragsters,
the old PKC was you get one kick in one light lights like PKA.
Yeah,
yeah.
Basically it was all the same shit right above the waist.
Kickboxing.
Yeah.
With the Silk Pants and that shit.
God,
it was brutal foam boots on.
So when I started,
I wasn't flexible.
Right.
That was a wrestler who had some boxing experience.
And the reason they did that was so boxers wouldn't come in and destroy
everybody.
Right.
So the karate guys could survive and do pretty well.
So that just having to get the allotted eight kicks per round.
I hated it because it was all kick above the waist.
I wasn't that flexible.
I was pretty shitty.
It kicks when I,
when I first started.
Right.
So it was just a waste of time.
And then I ran into the movie tie thing and the k one rules fights,
and I went,
this is my thing.
I can kick them in the legs.
Thank God.
Well,
I remember the first time we got kicked in the leg,
I was like,
oh,
this is such a game changer.
Because in taekwondo it was like,
it was illegal.
It was illegal to kick below the waist and it was legal to punch in the face.
So it was great for learning dexterity of the legs.
But the f the moment I started training with Thai guys and I got kicked once,
just once,
I want,
oh,
should do this,
this should be the thing that's so painful.
It's so painful.
It's weird.
It's not just painful.
It's like your leg goes dead.
Yeah.
It's,
it's this weird feeling.
You're like,
Oh,
Christ,
the SOA effective.
Yeah.
And also that you could do it from such a close range.
They can be in the clinch and blast somebody in the leg and her.
Right.
So the worst experience of my life sparring was Arthur Murray on a Souza.
He was the guy in the old ibcs in Brazil that laid Vander Lee silver's.
I wide open and all the meat was hanging down past his eye.
That was Arthur Mariana Sousa.
And they remembered that guy,
great striker,
trained in Holland for a lot of years and he would come up with Omri Pritesh and
live with me.
When Tash was the elite guy on the planet grappling,
right?
So we had the best of both worlds where the wicked striker and one of the best
grapplers in the world and he'd come up and then we'd just train hard,
right?
For six,
eight weeks at a time.
And Arthur started low kicking the shit on there.
Everybody at my gym,
we weren't great Muay Thai guys at that time,
but it,
the experience of watching he,
he started,
that's the thing,
he started getting to the back leg,
right?
Oh,
you can throw the cross and step outside and come back and,
and just tap me on the same spot over and over on your back leg and you're
always taking your weight off that leg off the cross.
Your weight goes on it.
Then it comes back off of it as you're stepping right when the kick hit.
So it's like Jello,
your clubs and yellow.
I'll just cut right to the femur bone every time he,
he kicked me like three times in a row in the exact same spot and that I went
and went
and he goes,
patch,
you know with a Brazilian accent.
He's like,
patch,
I know,
I know.
Kick you in that leg anymore.
And I go,
no dude,
I need to learn the hard way.
I said,
he's like,
all right,
cross low kick fall down balling.
He had Jens Pulver jumping like this,
like a monkey.
He was so afraid of his low kicks and then you fucked for days afterwards.
Yeah.
You don't want to get chicken
Gabe.
When you try to train,
you're all jacked up.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's an amazing skill that,
that the ties really figured out how to do it right.
And me Kill Catia and obviously had it,
a lot of martial arts had it,
but man,
the ties figured it out.
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy when you think about this one small island.
It's one small country and they,
because of gambling and because they had all those fights and they just figured
out a totally different method of training,
a totally different method of fighting.
Yeah.
Pretty impressive.
What do you think about the history of of Thai fighting between the,
the Laotians on the ties during times of peace,
the soldiers would fight each other and all that sort of stuff.
Just a bunch of scary people and they're the nicest people in the world.
The nicest people.
You couldn't meet any nicer people who will completely requeue.
It's so weird because like
when you meet ties,
especially even tie fighters,
they're so friendly.
They're so friendly and humble and warm.
And then when you watch him fight like
Jesus,
it's kind of crazy.
Yeah.
My,
so my,
my Muay Thai coach,
a guy named long longly,
his last name was not long way.
It was a lot longer than that.
But he was a stadium champion,
lived in Peoria,
Illinois and the ghetto and he had a little shitty basement with type with like
a,
uh,
banana bags and all that sort of stuff.
And I found the amount of sheer luck.
Somebody said,
there's this guy in Peoria that was a stadium champion.
He's the guy.
So I went to see him and he taught me how to clinch do clench work and he was
140 pounds maybe.
And he put you in the clench all the years of wrestling and everything else.
Didn't matter.
I mean I felt like a dog in a lake with a raccoon hanging on my head.
That's a,
to me
one thing that people don't realize that there are real fans of the sport is
that Moitai is a lot about grappling.
Yeah.
It's a lot about that clinch work.
And that's one of the things that I really like lion fight above a lot of the
other kickboxing organizations is that they let those guys work in the clinch
and elbows in the clinch.
And they say it's a,
again,
like we were saying about headbutts,
these elements are very effective,
so why remove them?
It's the what's tolerable to the politicians and the public and all the other
guard
clinch.
Everything should be there,
I think.
I think everything should be there.
I think the real issue is that the cage,
the real issue is the cage.
My opinion,
because the cage presents this artificial barrier,
right?
I mean I've been,
I'm beating a dead horse here because I've been saying they should find a
basketball courts.
I'm like,
if you're going to have a basketball game and a basketball court,
we serve a striker,
right?
Fuck yeah.
The rustlers are able to get you against the cage.
You Yank your legs out from underneath you.
I beat the shit out of you.
It is,
it is an advantage for the wrestlers.
It's also an advantage for the wrestlers and that a guy's not going to be able
to put his back up against the cage and get back up again.
You know,
Rambler has you down the center.
You're going to have to
earn that stand up.
You're gonna have to actually either reverse the position or figure out a real
escape because so many guys are so good at wall walking and there's so many,
and they're also good at defending a submission by keeping one side pressed up
against the cage and then attend tender back.
Yeah,
right.
I think that it's an artificial environment like the cage and it's also,
it's hard to see,
like if you're in the audience,
I mean it's,
it's actually better sometimes to be home watching.
I like it.
I like the boxing rings for fights.
I mean,
they go through the ropes now and then whatever.
Right.
But it's a lot better for people at home watching the,
and for the live crowd,
there's just not that cage.
I agree with that focus problem and cameras.
Right.
I agree.
I think Bella tour actually nailed it with their kickboxing ring because they
put this big circle around it so you can't fall through.
Like remember when Bernard Hopkins fought Joe Smith and his last fight,
he went through the ropes and landed on his fucking head.
Yeah.
I mean,
this is a terrible way for a legend to go out,
like to be,
this is,
it's the rope ropes were loose and he gets clipped while he was already going
down.
You just goes right through the hill.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous that he could fall four feet and land on his fucking head.
That was the fight where Bernard was talking tons of shit before the fight.
Right.
Was he talking lot of Shit?
He was talking a lot of shows.
His last fight,
you know,
and probably realized,
I mean Bernard Hopkins was getting his ass kicked by Antwan Eccles who trained
at pinions boxing gym in Iowa where I trained.
Right.
And one was scary dude.
He was scary.
He got,
he got side sidetracked and derailed by horrible management.
They really screwed his,
his career up.
But he was the scariest boxer that I have ever seen and been in the gym with.
I mean,
that guy would,
he's looking like he's punching at half speed and just crushing people was 16
ounce sparring gloves on destroying Pete.
I remember Anton Antwan went down to,
it was South America,
Ecuador or wherever the hell it was.
That was when,
uh,
Norris was fighting
Simon Brown,
Terri,
Terri Norris,
the smaller one,
right?
Yeah.
To turn,
uh,
Michael Nunn was defending his title there and Antwan I'll has got on the card
because Michael Nunn was the pound for pound best fighter in the world.
He was out of Davenport.
Iowa also were right.
So they were doing about your sparring and they were training down there,
getting used to the altitude and they,
Antwan one walked into the gym and he started sparring with three time world
champions and beating the shit out of all of them.
And they go,
dude,
you need to back off.
You need to,
you need to stop this.
And it's a month out from the fight and he doesn't care.
He's knocking the shit out of all these three time world champs.
And they'd go,
you're basically what Antoinne said to all of them was,
if you guys can't handle it,
stay out of my running.
Like I don't care who you are or what your titles are.
I'm going to rescue,
so toughen up.
I own the ring now.
Right.
That's how good he was.
What do you think about that kind of sparring though?
I think it's great.
Do you think it's great to just go to war?
I just,
you know,
you can,
there has to be a limit obviously,
because the ties don't do it like that at all.
Well,
here's the thing though.
That's because the low kicks and knees,
the elbows,
all that sort of stuff.
But it's also because they fight a lot,
right?
Yeah.
They're fighting every week,
you know,
so that,
that's,
you're smart.
But you know,
the thing is you can't,
and I say it a million times,
I've said it for years.
You can't become a race car driver by going down the highway at 55 he's just
don't have the reaction time.
You're not used to that.
See Highspeed that high endurance,
everything else that goes on,
you have to get used to that and everything slows down eventually.
Right.
With experience and time,
things slow down for you.
I can remember when I first started fighting kickboxing and everything was like
a tunnel this big and all I could hear was me breathing.
Right,
right.
Anything else.
But then later on in my career,
you know,
you'd see punches come at you and you'd move this slow,
but it was actually,
you know what I mean?
So it just,
it happens with time and you've experienced that with everything you've done,
right?
We come martial arts more accustomed to it and then you become more relaxed.
But I wonder like is there a way to keep the speed but at least take something
off the shots.
That's the thing is where you put the shin pads on the head gear,
the 16 ounce gloves,
you'd go at high speed,
you go hard,
you hit takedowns hard,
all that sort of stuff,
you know a couple of times a week.
But you,
you know,
you can't take that kind of punishment constantly.
But you know,
mornings would be conditioning,
strength stuff,
technique,
all that sort of stuff.
Then the nighttime was,
you know,
more high speed,
hard takedowns.
And as a coach I had to look and go,
all right,
tonight's takedowns.
But if I saw people getting tired,
fatigued and sloppy,
I knew an injury was about to happen.
Okay,
let's go to the ground now getting the guard,
lets go from there.
Let's do,
you know,
do some ground and pound drills,
this and that.
So I think,
you know,
it was,
it's important to go high speed until you start seeing mistakes happen because
of sloppiness fatigue.
That's when people get hurt.
And then you've got to pull the reigns back on everybody.
When you were running your gym,
the military fighting systems was the gym.
I mean you guys were the kings.
You got to think about who came out at your gym.
Matt Hughes,
Robbie Lawler,
I mean Jens Pulver,
Tim Silvia,
and then a host of other killers that people just forgot.
You know,
we had a lot of people obviously that would come and train with us.
Rich Franklin,
um,
Dave [inaudible] who was 85 pound champ for a while.
He was,
he was one of the best martial artists I've ever seen.
People don't even know about it.
The guy was incredible trained with Greg Nelson for a good portion of his
career,
obviously,
but I think we had 92 people made it to televise careers and I think 30 or so I
made it to the UFC.
I was pretty impressed.
So it's,
you know,
when I added it all up,
somebody asked me to do that and I added it all up and I went through all the,
the televised cards and I remembered it was I think 92 people and I thought,
you know that it's pretty impressive.
We had a lot of killers.
Yeah.
And you also were the first big Super Gym,
right?
You were the first big American gym that was producing like world champion
besides like the lions down.
I guess that's true.
The lion's den too.
Yeah,
I guess they were the first we had to go.
So you are,
you guys got rivalry with them?
Yeah.
We had a good rapport with the lion's den,
didn't produce as many world champions.
Me really big.
Basically at frank and Ken and,
and who else came out of the telling man?
Yeah,
a guy.
Metzger guy.
Massacre was a world champion.
Yeah.
Metzker a also had that kickboxing background.
He had more of an American style kickboxing background too.
And the wrestling,
he had Russell before and stuff.
So that helped him.
He had some great fights and pride to yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Metsker was super legit.
He's a smart guy too.
You know.
Metzker is an interesting fellow when you hear him talk about fighting and talk
about his career.
He's very open and honest about it.
The holistic health now,
you know,
he's,
he's pretty wise to that and I tell you what,
if you,
if you talk to him long enough,
he'll have you sold on some products,
you will.
They're like,
yeah,
but you know,
he's a guy that uh,
he suffered through that Vioxx Shit.
You know that Vioxx stuff that people were taking for heart attacks and all
that.
Stroke a stroke through Vioxx.
Yeah.
They pulled that shit off the market and when people were taking it,
a lot of people were taking getting strokes.
I think someone Vioxx and Celebrex,
Celebrex and other ones.
Celebrex was bad too.
Yeah.
There's a lot of weird drugs that people were taken for arthritis that I guess
it was like a blood thinner.
Right?
Is that,
yeah.
That was a lot of a lot of professional athletes who were suffering from
inflammation and pain and getting beat up and stuff.
We're all taking it and it was,
yeah,
it was wrecking people.
Yeah.
Um,
but anyway,
but back to your gym,
like when you guys were doing it,
you guys were kind of creating the roadmap.
I mean,
there wasn't really a lot.
I mean the lines then had their crazy,
um,
the,
the initiation that they would do right,
where they would run you through this and sync gauntlet.
Yeah.
It was similar to what I guess Ken had to go through in Japan,
but candidate put that together.
They had,
they had their own little methods as well.
I shouldn't say little methods.
They had their own food.
They were very big and very crazy,
but you guys like there wasn't,
there wasn't like,
now you have att have Tristar,
you have all these different gyms you could sort of model after,
you know Rufus is camp.
There's all these different places we can say,
oh,
all these elite fighters come out of here.
How are they doing it?
Oh,
I've trained with these guys,
I know their methods and here's what they do for strength and conditioning.
Here's how they take a here's how to do the recovery work.
Yeah.
You guys were basically at the front of the line.
There was nobody back there for you to look at.
Well,
what I was lucky enough to be,
like I said,
I wasn't a world class restaurant.
It was a good Russell.
I beat some very good wrestlers,
but that was not by any means even remotely worldclass.
Right.
I had some boxing experience.
I've been around some great boxers so I at least had that to start with.
But I recognized,
you know,
I want to be,
I want to,
I want to be good enough to spar 12 rounds with a worldclass boxer and hang,
hang and go an hour straight with a worldclass BJJ black belt and go back and
forth with them and battle tooth and nail to be able to hang in there.
You know,
the eyewear wrestling room during the summer with the hot club guys who were
absolute beast and frigging throw it around and bouncing off walls and spar with
good,
good kickboxers and be able to do all that stuff and then understand how the,
how to put it all together.
And I think that that,
you know,
at least enabled me to explain grappling and wrestling to a Stryker from Stryker
standpoint and vice versa.
You know what I mean?
So that was understanding angles from a striking standpoint,
from a wrestling standpoint and being able to explain it and understand people.
And then you got to read people,
you know,
their,
their personality,
right?
You got to coach everybody different.
You can't coach everybody the same way because some people want to get screamed
at and some people want a pat on the back of the hug.
You know what I mean?
It's just you got to read people differently.
Personalities are big deal.
When you were putting together,
when you were training fighters,
you first,
you started off,
when you first start doing it,
you were still fighting and you still had a couple of fights along the way.
Right.
But when you are putting together like training,
say if you were training fighter for a big fight in the UFC,
how did you put together their camp?
Did you leave it up to them in some ways?
Did you just have them attend the regular group training sessions?
Did you give them individualized attention?
I would,
you know,
I would give them individual attention.
Definitely.
I had to kind of figure out,
everybody's body was different.
How to find that,
that balance between aerobic and anaerobic endurance.
You know,
some people needed more of one or the other.
Um,
and then they'd come to team training and everybody,
you know,
you've got 40 guys in the room who are all a bunch of killers and you just get
new guys.
And everybody was pretty good about knowing this guy's getting ready for a
fight.
Don't fucking hurting.
That's,
that's really important,
you know,
so,
so we were pretty good about as a group looking out for somebody but pushing
them to their limit constantly or double team.
And I'm constantly,
you know,
every minute of the new guy jumping in on I'm type stuff and doing that sort of,
so it was,
um,
and obviously,
you know,
helping a guy like Hughes who wasn't the best striker,
we've got to do what we can to get them better at it,
you know what I mean?
Or a striker who can't stop the take down.
We've got to figure out how to help this guy.
I gotta put him with a bunch of wrestlers and just having constantly sprawling,
sprawling and sprawling and guys would alternate and shoot and shoot and shoot
and make them work at work at work at,
you know,
that was the,
it was just different for each guy I guess.
Now did you,
did you have anything specific that you would do in between camps?
Like say if you had a guy like cues and you say like he,
he wins this fight,
now I have some time off.
Would you start working with them on specific things like you would you have a
program you'd say like,
Matt,
we really got to tighten up,
you know,
your standup defense or we have,
if they were healthy and stuff like that.
Absolutely.
You know,
there's,
there was just guys that it's so hard for people to be well rounded.
It really is.
Especially when you're that good at one thing.
Hughes was such a powerful wrestler that and so good on the ground that it was,
you know,
it was a challenge.
So we had to definitely work extra with that.
Well,
Matt was the first guy who was a really great wrestler who also was outstanding
at submissions.
Right.
He really changed the game because like,
like when he,
that far
side arm bar and George St Pierre,
it has a very tactical move.
And to have a powerhouse wrestler hit that in a world title fight.
It's like that to me,
I think Matt doesn't get enough credit.
Maybe see,
just because you know,
time passes and you start looking at George Saint Pierre,
he started looking at all,
all these other guys with would lose the champ now.
And you sorta just forget like that Matt was the blueprint.
This is what happens when a really strong,
powerful wrestler absorbs the ground.
Right.
Scary dude.
Yeah.
That's,
that's where you go.
You're not a Bjj guy.
You're a,
you're a catch as catch can.
Rustler right.
You know,
you understand how to destroy somebody.
Control position,
beat 'em up and hit,
you know,
power submissions,
finesse submissions,
all,
all that different stuff.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's,
and when he was,
was in his prime,
I remember when he first,
I refereed his second fight and he destroyed some poor Brazilian and the guy was
a really good,
legit blackbelt and Hughes beat him half to death and it was in Chicago.
I refereed it and I walked up to me when I go,
did you ever come to Iowa?
I know I'll make you a world champ.
There's just no doubt in my mind.
That was the only guy I ever said that to.
The only guy I ever recruited to be honest with you,
for the most part.
So he shows up.
He drives three and a half hours from Hillsboro,
Illinois.
I've got bronchitis at the time,
which made it even worse.
And he goes,
we are,
I am,
let's,
let's get this workout in.
Right?
So we wrestled and grappled,
you know,
takedowns to submissions,
everything else.
And about 30 minutes into it,
I can't breathe in.
This guy is a monster.
I've had even 50 submissions and he's shaken out to all of them.
Literally just like bounced me off the walls.
It's so fucking strong.
I couldn't believe it.
And that was,
I was a strong guy.
I mean,
at the time I was probably mentioned three 65 could dunk a basketball and run a
four four 40 so I was not a slouch athlete when I was in my prime and I couldn't
believe this guy.
I had never experienced somebody my size being the strong in my life,
that it's armor strength,
shit,
his roots,
it is real.
And I grew up half the Russell farmers,
trust me,
the Royce Alger is,
and although Sundance,
right?
Yeah.
But I said to him,
I go,
hold on man.
I can't breathe.
I got bronchitis.
And he goes,
fuck you.
He goes,
I don't care what you got.
And I drove three and a half hours,
we're working out.
And he grabbed me and fucking train doubled me onto my back all the way across
the room slams.
It was like,
all right,
we're here,
let's get it done.
So I got him in one guillotine.
I lifted him off its feet.
I ran him backwards.
And Randy was hard as I could ask first end of the wall.
I mean,
I was just,
I was trying to kill him.
I was so pissed because he is just a freak and he went limp.
He went unconscious for a second.
So I let go of it and he slid down the wall,
hit his knees,
woke back up and train,
doubled me again onto my back and went back at it.
Right.
So we get done,
we get done with this hour or something,
work out of just go,
go,
go.
And I looked at him and I go,
dude,
what do you on?
And he goes,
what do you mean?
I go,
what are you taking you on some fucking steroids or what?
And he goes,
and he got pissed.
don't ever accuse me of that again.
He goes,
fuck you.
don't ever say again.
Never.
That was like the one thing where if somebody said to anything like that,
he was so offended because he was just a farm boy.
His brother was frigging just as strong if not stronger.
Yeah.
His brother was a gorilla too.
And his brother fought in UFC wants,
right?
Yeah.
And walking back to the locker room after that fight,
his brother mark goes,
that wasn't really all I expected.
I really,
it was fun,
but I don't think I'm,
I don't think I'm going to,
I don't enjoy that that much.
And he killed the guy.
He beat the shit out of it.
Right.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
I mean even identical twins,
they don't necessarily think identically.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Matt was a,
he was a real freak and a real important figure in the history of MMA,
you know,
like,
cause you gotta think 1993 it all starts.
And then from then on it's been sort of this learning experience,
trying to figure out what works and what doesn't work.
And in my opinion,
Matt is one of the big pieces to that puzzle because we had had some powerful
wrestlers of course,
yet Coleman and so many other guys.
And they were basically all about ground and pound.
I mean,
the only time Coleman got a submission,
the UFC was when he,
he fucking headlock Dan Severen or can't open,
take the lag in the head,
the head go head lock.
And you're going to eat something like that.
Yeah.
It was like a judo star.
Pressor a compressor.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
nobody wants to get stuck and that would that fuck a gorilla back then.
He was ungodly strong when I trained him for the pride Grand Prix,
right?
Yeah.
He called me up and he goes,
I want to come there and train with you.
And He'd lost two or three fights in a row at that point.
So he was kind of cannon fodder put into that pride Grand Prix.
He was just a name at that point.
And I go,
all right,
come you,
come here,
you got to do everything I tell you to do.
We're going to,
we're going to train hard.
I'm going to,
I'm going to torture you.
Got,
and he was like,
that's fine.
And he,
he wanted to come there.
I think because I had so many scary dudes at the time,
like Steve Ross who wasn't even a fighter,
could kill every fighter I've ever train.
I mean,
he'd just walk in the room,
take off his fatigues from hunting,
beat the shit out of everybody in the room and then go back out hunting or
fishing.
That's just,
that's,
that was Steve Ross and he didn't fight.
He fought four times and just goes,
you know what,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not into it,
but I'll come into the gym and help everybody get ready.
He,
he helped me coach my IFL team,
but he was the guy that after I fought Lindland,
when I got kicked out of my weight division,
when the UFC goes,
you gotta move up weight division.
I went,
why did they tell you you have to move up?
They go,
you've trained yourself out of a spot.
You have Jason Black,
rob Lawler and Matt Hughes all at one 70 they're all ranked,
I think in the s at the time,
top 10 in the world.
And they go,
and the,
I had done my comeback fight after losing the title,
Carlos knocked out Shonie Carter.
So in my contract it said that I have an automatic rematch clause.
Right.
And they go,
nope,
not happening.
You're moving up to one 85 and I go,
I'm not big enough for one 85 right.
But I realized at that point,
business wise how easily I could be discarded.
Right.
And it Kinda,
it kinda ruined me to be honest with you mentally.
It just,
I was like,
yeah,
I think I want to do this.
But neither here nor there.
Lindland after we fought,
he came to my gym to train for one of his fights and Steve Rusk is there that
day and rusk was a great Greco guy and now it's the Olympic silver medalist,
Greco guy going against a guy that's an unknown and Rusk ragdolls and we're
doing winner stays on the mat and Lynn Lynn gets taken down and linen won't
leave the mat.
He can't believe he's getting taken down by a known name.
Right.
So Russ does it to him again.
It does it to him again.
That was a tune him again.
And finally the whole team goes,
Lindland get off the mat,
dude.
Get the fuck out.
Wow.
Linen comes over and sits next to me.
He goes,
who the fuck is that guy?
I go,
let's Steve Ross.
He's just these,
Steve,
he's just everybody.
A lot of those guys in gyms out there that don't want to fight with their super
high level.
Danaher was telling me about some guys that he has in his gym that wreck some of
his best top guys that go in competition.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
No,
rusk was a guy who he grabbed,
it was Dave Strauser who fought in the UFC for awhile.
They was a tough guy.
It was very tough.
But Russ grabbed the,
he was in,
uh,
Dave's guard and he grabbed his foot and his shin bone and went like,
this one was going to just break his foot off.
Right.
That's how strong this guy was.
And Strausser taps out.
It gets up and looking at him like,
there's no way I'm ever grappling with you again.
He goes,
stay away from me.
I don't want any part of you ever again.
And uh,
Nick Ackerman,
who was a national champion wrestler,
he won the hodge trophy the same year.
Cael Sanderson the one they,
they were,
uh,
co recipients of it.
And that Ackerman was the guy who was a national champ who had,
his legs were gone from his knees down and Ackerman was almost as tall as me on
his knees.
That was another guy in our gym that was so strong that he would just,
he could just crush your ribs by squeezing it.
Just massive,
massive power.
It makes you wonder like,
what would it be like to grapple Carolyn when he's in his prime?
Cause even the great grapplers would grapple him and go,
what in the fuck is that all about?
He would,
yeah,
he was gut wrenching people and snap and spines.
Literally snap and spines.
Like when guys would flatten out,
when you'd see a 290 pound man panic,
like lay down flat on his stomach,
try to flatten out and do everything they can to keep from getting launched and
he would pick them up like a half empty sack of potatoes and a fucking slam the
Jesus.
You ever see his parents know?
Tiny little people.
Really?
Yeah.
They called them the experiment where they gym gymnast.
One was a gymnast or something and the other one was a little power lifter or
something.
I'm not,
I'm not sure.
But they were like five,
five.
Right.
And you know,
you see him,
he was just this fucking giant panther.
He really was like a panther.
Like he didn't,
he didn't even move like a big guy.
He moves like a small guy.
Yeah.
And he was a giant.
I think that,
you know,
there was probably some,
some sort of beat the system with that.
Oh,
what beaten the system that was a part of this system.
That fucking guy was on everything.
100% when you look at his face,
his forehead came forward and everything just looked massive amounts of growth,
all kinds of stuff.
Probably had them on growth and he was a little baby.
I mean,
they'd probably just shot him up with growth from the time he was little.
That's scary.
It's fucking terrifying.
But look what they're doing right now in China.
There he is.
Here's Carolyn in his prime,
like picking up a massive,
massive,
massive man.
This guys battle it to look at this.
Ooh,
I mean that guy,
that giant dude on the bottom probably never had anybody rag Tom like that
before.
And it was also like the way he would work out when you see like some of the
shit that he would do,
like some of his kettle bell workouts and shield cast that he would do with club
bells and steel plates and shit.
He was all about movement,
circular,
circular motions like so your gym having all that true functional fit,
like to see Indian clubs in your jam.
I went,
all right,
he gets it.
He really gets it.
Indian clubs,
I collect all the old ones.
Oh really?
And team woodlands,
the huge wood ones,
right.
All that sort of stuff.
So a guy named Ed Thomas taught me about true functional fitness long before any
of this crossfit crap and all this stuff came out,
right?
So Ed Thomas,
Dr Ed Thomas,
and I didn't know he was a doctor.
He just showed up at my gym one day.
He walks in a little unassuming dude and he goes,
hey,
he goes patio Simon,
Ed Thomas.
He goes,
do you have time for me to teach you some stuff?
And when I went,
sure,
you know,
whatever it was the middle of the day,
nothing was going on.
So he brings in Indian clubs,
kettlebells,
old med medicine balls,
old leather stuff.
And I at the time,
never seen any of this stuff.
I didn't know anything about it.
Well,
he was raised in the Turner halls in Davenport,
Iowa,
and that's where he learned functional fitness on the Turner Halls were brought
by the Germans here because the,
the German Jews,
Turner halls back in Germany to train a generation to become warriors,
to protect the nation.
And that's where that mentality came from.
So everything they did was cargo nets,
pommel horses,
Indian clubs,
uh,
heavy kettle bells,
all kinds of crazy just functional fitness stuff.
They would climb cargo nets,
serpentine and signed of them.
Uh,
they would swing the cargo nets and the kids would Serpentini in and out of them
as it was swinging.
All kinds of crazy stuff.
Right.
Um,
definitely the rings that were doing a lot of the rings stuff and power,
you know,
being able to do iron crosses,
all that sort of stuff.
That's the way they raised their kids.
And so he was at the time,
I think it's still is one of the first and foremost guys on functional fitness.
He was the guy that taught me how to train upside down with gravity boots,
doing all kinds of crazy stuff with medicine balls and kettle bells and bands
and everything else you could do standing up,
you could do upside down.
And he rebuilt me at the time,
but he came in,
taught me for an hour.
He said,
I'll leave this equipment here with Ya.
You can teach your guys what I taught you and I'll come back another time.
And I was like,
yeah.
And we were talking for a second.
I got on the phone and I turned around.
He was gone.
Well he said he was a three times in Vietnam.
He was a tunnel rat.
He signed up for extra tours.
He would go in and kill the Vietcong,
sleep,
sleep amongst the bodies,
and then go back out and find another tunnel and kill people again.
That's what you're going for.
Three years.
Just hardcore guy.
But I'm the guy that owned times at,
at the time,
his kid was trained and underneath me and he goes,
I heard you met a friend of mine.
And I go,
who's that?
And he goes,
Doctor Ed Thomas.
And I go,
well,
he didn't say he was a doctor,
but I could tell he was one of the most intelligent people I've ever met in my
life.
He goes,
yeah,
he's,
he's a scholar.
I mean,
this guy's a warrior genius,
right?
He's amazing.
And he's still,
he's still up in De Moines,
Iowa.
Haven't talked to him for a few years,
but that guy taught me what real fitness was about.
Wow.
This,
what year was this,
Dear God,
I don't remember.
I've been having to head so much or whatever.
Yeah.
Now you're great for a guy who's been hitting add as many as you,
but I never had a concussion.
I will say that we must have never had a concussion.
Really?
Nope.
But what is it?
Concussion.
Concussion is like,
well,
they check your pupils.
They're not dialing directly.
None of it.
None of them.
No concussions and all,
all that hard sparring.
Nope.
Never.
I find that hard to believe it.
He never got hit with a shot that they didn't see coming.
And I think that's,
nope.
Nope.
Wow.
Besides one time in a huge fight where a dude hit me in the side of the head
with a brick,
and I saw it last second,
I at least rolled with it.
And that didn't give you a concussion?
He,
I,
he,
uh,
it was a huge bro.
It was hip hop night at the nightclub.
I was bouncing that,
oh,
sounds like fun.
And the head and the Illinois Gang bangers and the Iowa gangbangers started
going at it and I tried breaking it up and they all attacked me.
Right?
Jesus.
So that's when I,
everybody was wearing,
it was winter time.
So I was choking people.
A guy got me in a headlock and I was grabbing people by their coat lapels.
And I'd hit my head in between his head and his head and I'd choke him
unconscious.
I'd find a new coat and I was working my way backwards out the front door and
finally snuck out of the headlock,
put him in a rear choke,
went backwards off the door.
He went limp.
I dropped him.
And then as I turned to get out into the street,
cause there was cops everywhere at that point.
There's dogs,
there's,
it's a snow storm.
Last second,
I see this coming at the side of my head and I duck and it bounces off my head
and this dude goes,
yeah,
like I was going to go down and I turned and I looked at him and rifle came with
a right hand and knocked him out.
And then the next thing you know there's just dogs diving into the crowd.
It was a good one.
That was a fun one.
Dogs,
that's not good.
No dogs work.
They work,
they work real well.
That's not good because they don't know who the fuck they're biting.
They might bite you.
They might bite the bad guys.
I mean,
who the fuck dogs don't know who the bouncer is?
You know they clear crowd out real quick though.
Fuck yeah they do.
And Almaas is that other using a,
back then it was shepherds really.
It was all German shepherds.
Yeah.
Melon was hadn't even entered the scene at that time.
I have a buddy who trains dogs who doesn't like Mal Mois says there too.
Two bloodthirsty said they were aggressive.
Yeah.
He goes,
they don't listen as well.
Interesting.
He goes,
he goes,
I can trust the shepherd.
He goes bite,
hold and release.
Yeah.
He's like,
if I stick a Malmo on and it goes to the fuck knows,
he goes also,
I don't trust him like as a pet.
Right.
You know,
he wants a dog that is is a real train bite dog,
but also good with the family.
Yeah.
I can hang out with your kid.
Right.
Well what's like iPhone mastiffs before,
right.
And massive mass stuff there.
You know,
I had brindle mastiff and I always loved to have males and I had a stalker for
three years who was a psychopath.
Right.
So that was when I got first mass duff king.
He was 210 pounds,
but he was a brindle scary look like a Bengal tiger.
Right.
And he that those dogs are so powerful,
you know,
at that size when they're truly in shape where you can't stop them.
And there were people that were using mass stuffs for police work and they
stopped using them because a 210 pound mass mastiff on a human being,
they can kill them really fast.
This is not a,
this is not a bite dog.
This is a dog that can just have a screw,
go loose and rip somebody,
throw it out in a heartbeat.
It just too big and powerful.
That hurts them if something hurts them and they think,
oh,
this is a fight,
right.
I'm just going to rip your fucking head clean off your body.
And that mass,
they've tested me a couple times for Alpha position in the house.
Oh No,
it was one time up,
a plastic bag in the wind was rolling through the woods and on my property and
he ran and he grabbed it and I told him,
you know,
King come here front.
And he came up to me and I put my hand on the plastic bag and he goes,
it's like,
all right,
here it is.
This is,
this is test time.
So I ripped the bag and it came out of his mouth.
Right.
And he really got pissed off at me.
I was testing him.
So at that point I'm like,
well,
I can't back down to it now because this is it.
So I put my fist against his teeth that he was showing and it was going to do it
till it sees this and he's like this with his teeth going there,
I'm going to do it,
Joe it.
And finally he turned and backed off and then I pet him and he was wagging his
tail and I was like,
all right.
Ooh,
that was,
that was kind of scary.
Right?
Parsons got in a fist fight with his massive.
Really?
Yeah.
He had a Neapolitan massive in college.
They got in a fist fight.
He goes,
it was a real fight.
And he goes,
I had a fight with my man.
I'm like,
maybe,
maybe you did more likely you punched your mastiff cause it does a real fight.
I wouldn't be talking to you.
You be chunks missing out.
Yeah.
You'd be fucking dead of Neapolitan.
That's a giant fucking dog.
I have a regency massive,
they're half massive Hass,
half pit bull.
Oh Wow.
About a buck 40.
That's a beautiful dog guy.
But he's a great dog.
He's old now.
He's like 12.
Okay.
He's,
he's had some,
some years under him.
Just socializing really good.
Oh,
he's a great dog.
He's the best over here.
Gets along with every dog.
Every person.
That's good.
I got him because his dad was on fear factor.
His Dad was an attack dog on fear factor.
People in a bite to eat and they try to run away.
And His dad,
his dad was also the,
um,
the dog that they modeled,
they used him for Cgi,
for the hulk.
Remember when the,
the original,
the one of the hulk movies with Nick naulty and Eric Bana.
Nick naulty was the bad guy.
He used the hulks dad and he,
um,
he had injected hulks serum and it was fucking dogs.
And so that the dogs would get to a certain point and it would,
uh,
you know,
to get angry.
They'd talk to them raw.
They would hawk out when they turn green now they were just big.
Okay.
Yeah.
It seems like they should.
Right?
Maybe they did.
No,
I don't think they did.
I think they just look at the findings.
Jamie found it.
Yeah.
Oh dear God.
That's scary.
That was like real bad CGI to boy when you watched that movie.
It's funny cause that wasn't that long ago,
right?
I think that was only like 15 years ago.
What year was that?
If you had to guess?
15 years ago.
So his dad,
my dog,
Johnny Cash,
his dad curly was in fear factor and that was literally what he was built.
Like wow.
But smaller than that,
obviously that's,
that's when he helps out.
So they took him and sort of exaggerated him.
Huh.
Basically looked like that you could find him just,
just Google regency mastiff curly.
He was a,
a famous stud cause it's just fucking ridiculous dog.
But the thing about the dog was when we had him on the set,
he would just fucking chill.
He was a black dog.
So none of those are him.
It's probably a lot of dogs named curly.
It's all right.
It doesn't,
but um,
the dog was just so friendly,
like,
and then when it was time to go,
when they put the bite suit on people,
it was hilarious because we were using [inaudible] for awhile and you get like a
big football player type dude is about two 40.
They can't bring them down cause they could hold onto it and they could,
that dog is only 60,
70 pounds.
He come around curly,
grab a hold of you and it would be like they got hit by a truck.
It would just go fly in and crash to the ground.
And one of the ones that we did was actually my friend,
ed's girlfriend was on the show.
And,
uh,
I knew her before.
It was like,
oh Jesus.
I felt bad because she weighed like a buck 10 and they're putting her in this
fucking bite suit and then curly hits her like literally like she got hit by a
tree.
Like someone took a tree,
one of those swinging trees and just boom.
Did she get her skills?
She was okay.
She,
she's a tough kid.
How many,
how many episodes of fear factor did you do where you were like,
this is horrible to do to one when they had a ride bulls one,
when they had a drink come there.
I'll
see the dog gets these people just boom,
get down bitch.
Like you're not going nowhere.
Oh,
nice.
But the problem was with these dogs is they bite so hard that if they get ahold
of a bone through the suit,
they can break a bone.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Anyway,
great dogs.
You had people drink Kombucha on free.
I don't drink.
I never saw.
What was it like?
It never aired.
It was a donkey come.
What happened was it got out on Tmz and then,
uh,
we,
they played horse shoes and a,
they had a day at a drink,
donkey come and donkey urine.
And uh,
yeah,
that's hard course.
It was hardcore.
That was,
there's two episodes where I said,
don't do it.
One of them was riding bulls and the other one was the donkey Kong people got
hurt.
Right.
The riding bulls that we got lucky.
No one got hurt.
We got luck.
Just roll the dice because this was the funny,
this fucking stunt man.
I'm sure you were working around stockmen before,
right?
Fucking animals.
Yeah.
They didn't give a shit broken bonds on mean anything to them.
Those guys are,
they're animals.
They're just some of the toughest fucking people for sure in all of show up.
And uh,
their attitude was like,
yeah,
that'd be fine.
That'd be fine.
And so my friend Perry,
who was the stunt guy was like,
don't worry
about it.
Boo.
There's stunt dogs or their stunt bowls.
Right.
I go there.
Stunt bowls,
fucking fold.
No,
he's Istanbul.
Did you have a conversation with that,
Paul?
Because he understands that's a ball.
That's how bull are so big.
Because we were,
I was standing next to the person while they were,
they were,
you know,
there's the pen and they,
they,
they sit on top of the ball and you're right there.
So I'm standing right next to him on the platform and I'm like,
don't do it.
There's no way you're going to hang on.
There's no,
we,
my first year in college wrestling at Sioux Empire up by the South Dakota
border,
middle of nowhere,
we got recruited by a guy that was an all American.
And I was state Johnny Johnson,
who was the coach up there,
right.
And myself and three other buddies,
Mike Wolf from American pickers.
Rustled with me that year up there.
Right.
And he's actually a tough guy.
Lot of people don't realize it.
Mike Wolf's actually a really tough dude.
Um,
but to keep ourselves busy,
we would go,
all the wrestlers would go,
and there was,
there was fields everywhere next to the college.
It was small junior college in the middle of nowhere.
Right.
So there was this huge Angus bull in the field right by the college.
So we would go over there and the first guy that could grab the bull's head
would win the money.
We put money in the pot,
right?
So we're running around the,
the owner,
the farm owner,
the farmer pulls up one time in his pickup truck and he goes,
what do you idiots doing?
We got,
we put money in a pot and the first guy that can grab the bolts head wins and
you know,
that's,
that's the game we're playing,
right?
And he goes,
you got to stay off my property,
man,
knock this shit off.
And then we got to where the sheep would always escape another farm and come
onto the lawn of the college.
And Mike Wolfe and I got in trouble one day.
We'd take these,
these rams and we'd smack them in the forehead,
palm in the forehead to get them to jump up on their back legs and try and smash
us.
And then we'd sidestep them and headlock him and throw him and stuff.
But that's,
that's what we were doing for fun back then.
So,
uh,
Mike,
Mike Wolfe,
one of the ladies that worked in the cafeteria sauce doing it and she goes,
you boys leave those animals alone.
Quit.
Stop doing that.
Right.
That's cruel.
And it wasn't hurting him.
We were just having the phone.
We were born college kids,
right?
And uh,
I said,
yeah,
but you should see what squirrel does to them.
And Squirrel was one of the basketball players from east Saint Louis who played
on the basketball team up there.
And we had guys from Miami,
south side of Chicago,
East St Louis,
you know,
just tough ghetto kids who got thrown into this,
this,
uh,
farm atmosphere.
It was totally foreign for them,
but we made the joke,
and this was a very religious cafeteria lady and I said,
you should see what squirrels doing to them.
And the next day we came in for lunch.
She was scolding squirrel about beastiality and he's looking at me.
So yeah,
that was good times.
Good Times Fan.
Yeah.
That's a ridiculous thing to do with your time.
We had nothing else to do.
I understand.
You should find something else until he needed somebody.
Some guidance.
Well that's,
that's the uh,
hey warden Iowa,
which was right on the South Dakota border,
tiny little town.
The college was there.
And One night I went drinking and I got in a fight with a bike gang and they
were beating me with pool cues.
But if that's not,
you know,
whatever it happened.
But I had a guy,
a biker was at the urinal and I walked into the bathroom and he goes,
quit dragging your feet.
Eight man.
And I go,
you know,
people that mind their business don't get the shit kicked out of him.
Right?
And he goes,
bring it.
So I crushed the toilet with him,
right?
I beat his head on the toilet and powder the toilet.
It's like roadhouse.
And,
but then the other bikers heard the commotion and I came out of there and they
all started beating me with pool cues.
And I was fighting my way out of there and I made my way out.
I got back to the school and my scalp all split open and everywhere.
And my arms are beat to hell from blocking pool cues and I lost my gold
necklace,
so I had to go down there the next day to go back and get my frigging necklace.
It was a big rope chain necklace that my girlfriend at the time of bought for me
and I walked in and I go,
I lost my chain here last night.
And the owner goes,
yeah.
He goes,
you put five people in the hospital last night.
don't ever come back here again man.
Don't,
don't come back.
This is so that's just the way it was dealt.
The Iowa,
that was Iowa.
That's what we did for fun.
Has such a reputation for a tough guys when it comes to wrestling.
I mean the,
I will wrestlers,
there's,
it's like,
you know like there's like Thai kickboxers,
Iowa wrestling.
It was always this thing.
It was almost synonymous with Iowa when Gable was coaching the eyewear wrestling
team beat up the football team and the basketball team on numerous occasions
he'd have to go get those guys out of jail.
They just beat up the whole team.
Well,
I can only imagine,
you know,
if someone actually thought they were a tough guy and they talked to those tough
guys,
it's like,
well,
we've got to show you something because you're going through this life with his
delusional perspective and a blue and the Ed bannock and guys like that.
Just King Mueller back in those days,
some very,
very scary wrestlers.
I don't think people truly understand the difference between them and regular
human beings.
I just don't,
I don't think they've ever expire.
I think you have to like just lock up with them to experience it.
The explosiveness,
the tendon strength,
just the power of the sheer of just violence.
If those guys can bring in a short burst of energy,
it's until you get used to it and you see it all the time and in fighting a guy
who's never trained with guys at that level of athleticism,
right suddenly find themselves getting mauled by a superior human being going,
Holy Shit,
I never had any idea a human like this even existed.
Well,
you see it when you'll well fights.
Yeah.
When you,
well,
Romeo gets ahold of guys when DOL,
you're talking about a guy who metaled in every single international competition
he ever and beat Cael Sanderson when was was 18 years old,
right?
Yeah.
That's a scary dude.
Beat him twice.
Yeah,
he's a fucking monster and when he gets a hold of guys,
he could see the way he rag dolls people.
You're like,
Holy Shit.
But that's what it is.
It's just this next level athleticism,
next level strength,
next level technique.
And then also just being
forged in the competition of that Cuban Westling program.
Did you see the podcast I had with him last week?
No.
I had him on last week with Joey Diaz and Joey Diaz translated for him and they
went back and forth like,
Yo,
you always try to speak,
speak as much as he could in English.
And then Joey would sort of translate the stuff that he couldn't write.
He just detailed his,
his time in the system and the Cuban wrestling system and how intense it was.
I wouldn't,
I mean,
think about their communist country.
That's your ticket.
Yeah.
To at least leading a halfway decent life.
We'll just to eat.
He was talking about the difference between the way the elite guys would eat in
ways where they would sleep.
They would get three meals a day,
the other guys would get to,
and the food would be better.
Everything would be better.
That would motivate you to win.
Yeah.
And they're all together.
That's the thing.
They're all trained together.
So the guys who want your spot or right next to you,
everybody knows like,
Oh,
you got a hurt wrist.
They know.
Everybody knows everything.
Right?
And he's like,
that competition just makes you a machine.
And the guy that's eaten two meals a day,
once,
three meals a day,
fuck,
Yay.
Does.
Yeah.
And then,
and then on top of that,
you have these fucking incredible genetics.
I mean,
the Cubans have a unfucking believable genetics.
It's just a,
an amazing pot.
But that's,
that's really one of the more fascinating things about competition is to see all
these variables.
And it's to see like when you think you've reached this high level,
I'll look at this,
there's another level past that.
There's another level passed that and let you get,
you see guys who in no way shape or form should be a champion or upper echelon
athletically or genetically,
but they figured out how to do it.
Right,
right,
right.
Just super smart.
Yeah.
But you see a guy,
you know,
I would say,
if you were to see,
well,
let me think,
smiling,
Sam,
Alvin on the streets.
Right,
right,
right.
And you got in an argument with him for whatever reason you think I'm going to
kick this guy's ass.
He's wearing a sweater with a tie underneath it.
It looks like a car sale,
guys.
The guy's tougher than shit.
He's just would've never guessed.
You'd never guess.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those guys,
right?
Evan Dunham,
you'd never know.
You look at Evan,
done them.
Looks like a nice gentleman.
I'll beat the fuck out of you.
And you just go home and go,
I'm never fighting the,
this is just the stupid.
Yeah.
Well you'd learn that in Jujitsu too.
I remember when I first started training,
I would get choked out by guys to just looked like nothing.
Compared to the weight 150 pounds.
Well,
the,
especially now like I think now a Jujitsu is really been a adopted by a lot of,
uh,
like Eddie calls.
I'm like nervous acids,
right?
Because they really are like these guys who are just really smart or into the
technique and into the fact that it's,
it's a Jujitsu by a computer programmer.
Yeah.
That level of thinking through things and that's cool.
I've rolled with a lot of guys like that and go this,
this is stupid.
This guy is,
especially now with the leg lock game,
with a leg lock game,
it seems like strength is less of a factor.
You know,
wouldn't,
you guys are isolating legs and you're constantly defending against that and
whatever strength that you do have in your back and your core and your upper
body,
you're not really getting a chance to utilize it.
You're just trying to defend if you don't understand the positions.
Right.
And they get,
they get deep,
they get a couple of steps in on you and you're like,
oof.
You know,
it doesn't take a strong guy.
And I always loved leg locks.
I love leg locks.
And the guy like Dave Manet,
Matt Hume,
those guys were all sick leg lockers,
right?
Yeah,
sure.
Eric Paulson,
good leg lock or a lot of those guys that were the catches catch can and the
Combo.
Who did?
I'm Matt Hume Wrestle in that.
Do you remember that one time were Peretti put together a thing with Dan Gable
was the commentator with Peretti.
He went against an Olympic wrestler.
I'm pretty sure my Johnson Kenny Monday.
Kenny Monday,
I think it was Kenny mom.
Cause either Kevin because Kevin Jackson lost the Sherman Jackson loss to frank
shamrock.
No,
that was you have,
so that was dance Severin no,
Dan,
Dan Henderson House to Frank.
Frank got him in a foot lock.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think it was Kenny Monday.
That's when Kurt Angle was calling the action and I was sitting next to Kurt
Angle and Kurt was asking me questions.
What's,
what's he doing?
Right?
So what do you what to say on the air and stuff,
right.
Yeah.
That was an interesting thing.
That submission tournament.
I thought it was great.
I thought if they were to ever do it again,
I think,
but they kind of do that now anyway.
They do do that now,
but for whatever reason it doesn't get that much attention.
Although Eddie,
Eddie bravos figured out a way to give it a little bit more attention.
If he's seen combat Jujitsu a little bit,
they're doing it basically like pankration style slaps like open hand strikes.
Right.
And um,
you know,
it opens up,
it's,
it's also like what we were talking about before with,
um,
there's some stuff that you can get away with an MMA because there's no head
buds.
There's some stuff that you can get away with another styles like in,
in kickbox even cause there is no clinching and there's no elbows,
right?
There's all these different little things.
Well with,
with Jujitsu,
there's a lot of positions where a guy could just smack you in the face.
You'd have to let go the lock.
And now guys are doing that with combat Jujitsu and it's a good intermediary
step between,
I think it's a good way to find out if you're meant for MMA to that too.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I find that he,
I've always found Eddie really interesting.
He's a trip.
He's a trip and you can tell he's a thinker,
you know what I mean?
He's a,
he's a very analytical guy,
very analytical grappler with great flexibility.
I just always would watch them go,
this guy's fucking slick man.
And he knows a lot of shit,
especially when it comes to Jujitsu.
And I'm talking,
you know,
I'm,
I'm gonna see him tomorrow morning.
Oh really?
What are you doing?
Uh,
you know,
Sam triply?
Sure.
No Sam very well.
So I'm doing that show.
Um,
and,
and he's going to be there.
I want him to explain flat earth to me because he's not going to be able to,
I want to know.
But this is what it is.
Eddie thinks that everybody's lying,
that everybody and NASA and the government,
and because of that,
I believe he has a blind spot and that he lived there telling you the world's
around.
He's saying,
well,
it can't be round.
Right.
And it's not a good way to think.
No,
but it's the same reason why he's so good at Jujitsu.
It's cause he sees an idea and he just pursues it and chases after it turns to
the right digits is like,
it's all,
you know,
it's all quantified.
It's all right there.
Two bodies.
It's all very simple.
There's no
mystery.
Right.
You know,
it's just a figure.
It's just figuring out a puzzle.
Yeah.
But I can see how people get that way because I was a guy who,
you know,
not to go off on a tangent,
but I think it's fun to think about.
In 1971 when I was a young boy standing in line in Albia,
Iowa with my grandma and my mom when the farm collapse was happening and when
Nixon took us off the gold standard,
right.
Shit fell apart for the farmers right away.
And my grandma was one of the first people in line to get her money out of the
farmer's national bank in Albia,
Iowa.
And she got it out.
And I remember still to this day,
standing there and asking my mom and my grandma,
what the hell is going on?
Why is this happening?
What's going on?
You could see the panic.
The farmers went for blocks right from all around that part of Iowa and it just,
I think that's what started the wheels turning in my head about being a
contrarian thinker.
There's real conspiracies and there's real things where people misunderstand the
actual facts.
Right?
Flatters not one of them.
No,
not,
it's just not,
I mean,
there's so many stuff.
looked snipers used the curvature of the earth to calculate ballistics.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's just,
it's a real thing,
right?
I mean,
there's plenty of shit that's not real,
but I want Eddie to tell me,
I want him to explain it is going to be frustrating.
I don't know if I believe in anymore.
He might've let it go by now.
I'm a hope and he did.
Right.
I don't talk to him about it anymore.
I just,
we had a few conversations about it on the podcast and initially he thought it
was stupid.
He thought the flat earth concept was too,
but,
and then all of a sudden he started being open minded to it.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you saying?
Like what the fuck are you saying?
This is crazy.
And he's like,
and he kept going to the fake the moon landing.
They send me the same people.
Right.
If,
if they did,
that was a long fucking time ago.
You're talking about people right now.
There's satellites all over the world that they,
there's a lot of people that think satellites are fake.
Um,
I think anything's dinosaurs aren't real.
Yeah.
Wow.
You know what's interesting and I never,
and the first time I fought in the UFC I went into things.
Dinosaurs or business.
Yeah.
It hurts.
Hurts my head.
I went into the,
the production trailer and my first UFC,
I wanted to see what was going on in there.
Right.
That was,
that always intrigued me how TV was put together.
Right.
And that was lucky enough to bring my daughter to one of our broadcast with
access TV and Lonnie,
who's,
he's the expert to find the satellites.
He's got an APP on his phone.
If you ever seen guys do that.
No.
He has an app on his phone where he can punch it in and do this across the sky.
It's spot all the,
the satellites.
Right.
Ah,
interesting.
So he knows how to dial into them.
Call Up.
No,
the,
the coordinates to turn the,
the dish towards and lock onto a percentage of the satellite,
you know,
receptor to get it being back down,
all that sort of stuff.
So he was teaching my daughter how all that stuff was done.
And it was first time I'd ever seen,
it was like,
this was pretty,
pretty amazing stuff.
But yeah,
you can see the curvature of the earth and how the satellites are set across the
horizon.
Right?
Well,
you could track satellites.
The thing is,
these guys don't even believe in satellites.
Here's what the problem is.
If someone has no,
and they put
together a video and that video,
they're articulate and they sound calm,
they use big words and they show you images that they're claiming show that the
earth is flat,
that there's an ice wall outside of Antarctica,
and that the government won't let you go there.
They start saying all these things,
if there's no one there,
no like Neil degrasse Tyson type guy.
There he's go,
hey,
no,
that's not true.
And here's why.
And here's how we know and here's what we found out and here's a test you can do
yourself.
Here's how you can figure it out,
right?
And here's Wiki,
what you could find online and here.
And like for the longest time they were trying to say that there was no full
pictures of the earth.
That the,
uh,
the,
the earth,
like every photo you see,
if the earth is a composite,
no,
does it fucking Japanese satellite called the hemo Ari aid.
It takes full,
full images of the earth.
High resolution,
every 10 minutes you can go Google it,
you can watch them.
There's the,
NASA has one too.
There's giant photos of the fucking earth from 22,000 miles out or whatever the
hell it is.
It's real.
It's fucking real.
Like there's a lot of shit to think about.
That's fascinating.
That's not one of them,
like that's been solved.
You know,
I'm into the geopolitical and domestic policy shit.
Right.
That's where I,
I was drawn more about what's really going on,
you know,
behind the news,
all that sort of stuff.
This is bullshit.
And I was lucky to train a lot of law enforcement and then military high level
military and get connected to Intel guys who go,
pat,
we need to talk like,
no,
you're completely off.
Let me explain things to you.
Right.
It was like,
as far as like,
what were you completely off about?
Well,
I can tell you what I was right about when I called up my buddy and I go,
hey,
four years ago,
whatever it was,
four and a half years ago,
I go,
we're funding Isis,
aren't we?
He goes,
well,
yeah.
Yeah.
They,
those the go between guy.
What do you think?
I'll news for Isis friggin Al Shabaab.
What are you fucking think?
So why did they fund isis to take out Syria?
It was obvious,
right?
The mujahideen in Afghanistan,
the frigging take out the Russians,
but the way I looked at it was when that was going on funding,
the Mujahideen was to bankrupt Russia,
right?
Right.
We wanted them to go bankrupt and it worked.
Reagan was,
was a genius in that park.
The diabolical part of course is Russian and American both fighting over the
resources of Afghanistan.
Right.
But Isis was just theirs.
That's some weird shit.
When you have a 50,000 man army just appear out of nowhere with professional
cameramen and editors and producers and directors making the high level films
that they were putting out,
where it's every three seconds they're cut in different angles professionally
put together films of people being burned.
I go,
this is this,
this is too weird.
This is too weird.
You know when people stop talking about,
do you remember when they blame
Ghazi on some bullshit video,
some video that someone made,
right?
What was it like the tears of Muslims or something like that,
or I forget that.
Nobody even knew it existed.
Nobody knew it existed.
And everybody knew it was bullshit.
And they were pushing that as a,
like this is what
was the motivation behind.
And everybody was like,
what have you had Perato on your show?
No.
Who's this?
[inaudible],
what's his name?
Former seal.
What's his name?
Toronto.
Rol Name.
T a presumptive.
His last name's Perato,
but I think he's a former seal.
There were several seals obviously that ran to try and help,
uh,
the ambassador and some of the other guys,
Toronto lived through it.
But you know,
he,
when he talks about it,
it,
they're moving massive amounts of weapons through Libya,
into Syria,
into other places in the Middle East.
Right.
There's just a fact that it's happening.
And that whole thing going down,
I think was a way for them to just cover it all up in a remove and erase any
people that knew about it.
You know what I'm saying?
That's the way it spells out to me.
Pretty obvious because it's documented.
It's all documented that weapons were being moved.
And if you look at,
um,
arsenal of weapons manufacturing in Bulgaria.
So Leon had goats and shy by who I had on my podcast,
the conspiracy farm.
Right.
She was the Bulgarian reporter that got fired for it.
Now you had a podcast?
Yeah,
it's called the conspiracy farm.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I want to Google it.
We don't,
we don't start the conspiracies.
We just add the water,
but I've got to click the name.
Yeah.
My cohosts Jeffrey Wilson.
He's a really bright guy.
Cool.
Cool game.
Yeah.
So we have fun with tee shirts.
Can I wear conspiracy theory that was going to bring you on and why he shipped
me once and I will.
I will.
Okay.
Yes.
So it's a bar.
It's a barn.
It's a barn with a satellite and the satellite dish down next to the bar.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's it.
Right.
And he's doing it out of Iowa.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's pretty,
yeah,
that's right.
But,
um,
arsenal weapons manufacturing,
she exposed,
the Isis fighters took here.
I took her to their weapons cache.
It was,
and there was massive amounts of artillery rounds,
depleted uranium stuff,
small arms stuff,
and it was all arsenal weapons,
Bulgarian weapons,
right?
And she got fired for exposing it.
Now at the same time,
silk way airlines,
who is a Azerbaijani airline,
they're manifest,
got exposed by Bulgarian anonymous with manifest of all the white phosphorous
weapons,
the depleted uranium,
our artillery rounds,
all these shipments,
massive shipments going into Turkey,
going into Libya,
going into the Ukraine,
right?
We're a bunch of shit was going down there and every one of those places who
showed up,
the broker,
the deals,
John Mccain,
Whoa,
right?
And look,
we can't prove it,
but there's people telling me that potentially there's an offshore company that
owns a big percentage of arsenal weapons manufacturing in Bulgaria,
right?
So that's the kind of stuff I'm going in.
I'm into who's who's causing it?
Why are they causing it?
The truth,
I'm just a truth seeker.
Right,
right.
Would you seem like that kind of guy?
For sure.
Do don't you think that that stuff is exposed at a level that's never been
possible before because of the Internet and that these people are probably used
to operating in a certain way that they'd been doing for decades and now they're
having to adjust.
Yeah.
Well,
and when people like you just doing these podcasts and talking about it,
which opens the minds of other people and has them thinking about it,
we,
you know,
w w who are the people screaming the most of the,
I wasn't,
uh,
I wasn't even a Trump supporter.
Right.
I'm a rand Paul Guy.
You've got to fucking Rand Paul Shirt on,
right?
The Ron Paul Guy,
you've got to teach him take down defense off of a one a lawnmower.
Right.
So you got blindsided in his defense,
right?
Yeah.
But it was at about this neighborhood tack.
Those neighbors alluded tech.
Right.
Good Times.
You know,
but,
uh,
it's a risky thing to do live right next to a guy on a,
tag them.
Right.
Like you're fucking burning the bridge.
I don't even know what kind of sentence that guy got though.
I don't,
I haven't kept up on that,
but that was given sentence.
Yet during the presidential run,
I was given speeches for Rand Paul,
a couple of them to introduce him.
So I give a speech and then bringing them out and I got to know him a little bit
better in Iowa.
Yeah.
Amazing Dude.
We had great conversations.
I'm a big Fan of his dad.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
but the people that are yelling at the most now about Trump and all the other
stuff,
you wonder what they're guilty of,
right.
The deep state is just,
it is a way of doing business right there.
Smash and grab.
Um,
there's pay the play smash and grab his me as somebody who is very powerful in
government,
going after an industry,
crushing it,
ruining that stock.
And then my buddies by the company,
right when the stock collapses and then bringing it back up like the Gi bill for
a University of Memphis,
we go after it.
No longer will there be any GI bill money put toward that.
The stock goes from 100 down to $3.
Obama's buddy goes in and buys it,
then they go,
wow,
we're going to allow GI money to go back into it.
Now stock goes back up.
Right.
That's the kind of shit that's going on.
It's,
it's some bad stuff.
And we just do our best to follow it.
Educate people.
And we have a lot of people will say,
you're,
you're not,
you're wearing a tin foil hat.
But we just talking about Jamie,
about,
uh,
something that you'd seen about politicians being exempt from insider trading
rules.
Someone on Twitter.
I couldn't,
I'll find the name later.
But,
uh,
if this guy,
he told me about this guy,
his name is Peter Schweizer.
He's a Stanford per secret empire.
So that's the book.
That's the book you want to,
he wrote Clinton cash also.
There's another book that he hit me up to about.
Yeah.
But this is the one that had,
have you had him on your show?
And I have not.
That's a guy that had been here.
I would love to have them on how the American political class a hides corruption
and enriches family and friends.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
There's,
that Shit's real.
Yeah,
without a doubt that shit's going on.
I mean,
look,
we were just talking about this recently,
about how half of what it is to be president and is to get yourself into a
position where after you're out,
you can make these crazy speeches for these bankers.
Like why is that?
Like,
I mean it's,
it's almost like our man,
I,
you,
I told you there was a time when a good friend of mine who was an agent me at
the time got me involved because of all the years in MMA and martial arts,
I've met people from all over the world who had eventually moved in the piece up
positions of power in government or cities or this or that.
And so they said,
we want you to help us get our foot in the door to sell waste to energy
projects.
So it was basically a,
a facility that bonds anything garbage.
I mean,
you can burn tires and the thing at low oxygen levels,
so the emissions are very low,
but that generates electricity,
right?
And in Europe it was everybody from the city,
uh,
province that contrary and the European Union,
everybody wanted a piece of the projects.
Right.
That's just the way they do business in Europe and South America and other
places like that.
They have to have a different model for it here for the corruption.
Right.
They just do things differently here and that's just the way it is.
They've made adjustments and either way they're going to find their way around
it.
Yeah.
The idea that there's no corruption is ridiculous.
Right?
No one thinks that.
So it's how much corruption is there and how many people are out there exposing
it and putting their neck out there to expose it.
That's a big part of the problem because if you really know about it,
that means you're probably entrenched in the system too.
Yeah.
And the cognitive dissonance of the,
the citizenry of knowing that Hillary Clinton and a few other people sold,
you know,
the document just came out.
It was 15 million kilograms,
15 million kilograms of depleted uranium,
yellow cake.
Right.
Sold to the Russians.
At what point in any part of a discussion on any planet,
is it okay to sell your enemy 15 million kilograms of frigging uranium?
What was the justification behind it?
They agreed that this is a fact.
This is what's a fact?
It's a fact.
Agreed.
I mean there's this,
is there any dispute that this is a fact?
No.
There is no,
there's no they,
but they sit there and use the excuse.
Well,
there was eight other people that had to sign off on this.
Right?
What does that mean?
Right,
but it was suddenly that company,
suddenly that company invests $145 million in the,
in the Clinton Foundation.
Yeah.
That's a big problem.
That Clinton Foundation is fucking insane and all these people that were blind
supporters of Hillary that didn't look at that like,
how do you not,
how do you not find a giant problem with that?
Right.
It's,
and that book by Schweitzer talks about it,
he goes in detail about that stuff.
Yeah.
I'm sure.
How's this sobriety?
I'm surprised that that's what that was just going to say after the Clinton cash
to the Russians.
Do Clinton cash was bad enough.
This one's even worse.
I'm surprised he's not dead.
I wonder how many people are actually reading it.
You know,
I just,
I feel like they think that there's always going to be a certain amount of that
stuff out there and they just tolerate it and they just,
as long as it's not really fucking up their business,
cause it's not,
the politicians are still allowing it.
Law enforcement still allowing it and no one's really going after them.
It makes you wonder,
like if Hillary had actually gotten into the White House and she faced the same
scrutiny that Trump is facing right now over the Russian pros,
we know none of this would be uncovered had she won.
Right,
right,
right.
I know that.
Right.
All of this stuff would have been swept the rug.
Yeah.
Most likely.
And all this stuff with McCabe and uh,
uh,
struck and page and call me and all these people of going out of their way to
try and derail Trump to get these FISA court,
frigging spa surveillance,
frigging warrants to spy on a president elect and then a sitting president.
Are you kidding me?
At what point is our people not,
not charged with treason for that?
Right.
When
they were [inaudible],
they were doing this spine before he ever won the presidency.
Don't you think that if he was doing something wrong with the Russians,
they would have frigging made it mainstream news and,
and bustled him for it?
Yeah,
there's for sure some dummies and his staff that made some inappropriate
meetings and had some,
I mean,
they definitely had some intentions.
Well,
but they had something on him.
The way I look at it as this,
I mean,
if you win the presidency,
I'm going to send whoever is underneath me.
If I'm the president,
we have to have meetings with diplomats from other countries to make the
transition.
That's,
that's part of the,
that's part of the deal,
right?
It really is.
That goes on.
That's just the way it is.
But that's not what they're talking about.
They're talking about before the presidency.
They're talking about having meetings with Russians long before,
right.
Where they had planned this whole thing out.
Like they got enough.
They're all dirty.
They've got nothing.
They got nothing.
I mean like if they had something new,
it would be out there.
It's that projection and diversion and everything else.
Because you know the Podesta's we're doing lobbying for the biggest friggin
Russian bank in the world.
Right?
Right.
In Washington DC that it never comes up.
It's almost like there's too many things to pay attention to that.
It's like they did everything.
They just how you,
how do you keep up?
How do you,
how do you corral it?
All,
all the corruption for the stock market to natural resources to everything.
Right.
It's almost,
there's too many things to take,
pay attention to.
Yeah.
It's,
it's mind boggling.
It's like a giant room full of spaghetti.
Yeah.
And you're in the middle of it.
Not just doing this.
It's fucking exciting way to put it.
That is what it's like.
Yeah.
It does that to your brain when you tried to comprehend all of it.
When you,
when we do shows and we talk about this stuff,
it's,
it's mind boggling.
How many episodes have you done?
We've only done like 50 so far,
but we've got listeners in 130 countries.
So we're doing pretty good.
That's nice work site.
Well you get more now for sure.
Well cause you're kicking ass.
Thank you.
Well we're gonna I mean promoting it here.
Right here.
Conspiracy farm.
Go download it.
Check it out.
Um,
so when you started this out,
what was the intention?
Just to something you're interested in?
You know,
I did Jeffery's podcast,
it's me speaking to you.
And at the very end of it it was three conspiracy questions.
True or false,
right.
Okay.
And I said,
can I elaborate on them though?
Cause it might be something that I've actually researched.
He goes,
yeah,
sure.
So we,
at the end of it,
he asked me,
I forget what the questions were,
but after we were done,
I go,
Hey,
I've always wanted to do this podcast and I want to call it the conspiracy farm
and I want to talk about geopolitical domestic policy stuff.
Unless anything goes,
I love it man.
He's like,
yeah,
let's,
let's do it.
Absolutely.
So we've had great guests,
you know,
a couple of navy seals,
former Spetsnaz terrorist hunter.
Um,
well if you're going to do Sam Tripoli's podcast,
tin foil hat,
just understand that it's a different kind of conspiracy theory podcasts.
It's like his big foot psychic.
Like those kind of questions.
You're going,
oh dear God.
And expect to get a contact high from the room.
I always wanted to ask you about that George Saint Pierre stuff with Ufos.
I think its head trauma.
Yeah.
Where did he,
did he have sex with this hot green check?
Maybe did,
but if I had a gas,
the way he was describing things is very similar to the way people describe
things when they've experienced successive head trauma.
Really?
Yeah.
Because he missed his time.
He's memory's not not good.
He'll get home and then he'll let have groceries that he bought and left in his
trunk and not even realize it.
And they will go out to his trunk and the rotten and he's like,
I don't even remember going to this door.
Wow.
And you know,
so he's got,
I think he's got this idea that this,
these glitches in his mind,
it's not a fucking coincidence that the guy got punched in the head.
I think they did a stat before the Bisping fight.
I think it was more than 800 times you got hit in the head and his UFC career.
Forget about all the gym training.
Forget about all the other stuff.
Right.
And forget about the fights outside the UFC.
Did he had before he got into the UFC when he was in Tko remember?
Yeah.
So he's experienced a lot of head trauma.
One of the symptoms of head trauma is memory loss issues and mean.
Um,
and Hendricks hit him hard a lot.
Yes,
he did.
Yeah.
And he's only one guy that hit him hard.
I mean,
a lot of guys hit him hard.
Matt Serra scrambled is fucking brain.
I mean,
a lot of guys hit him hard and that's just outside of sparring.
that's us outside of everything else that he's done sparring with Rory Mcdonald
and Wonderboy and all the other guys that he had a spar with.
Yeah,
I think that's most likely what it is.
People who have been,
who've experienced a lot of head trauma,
that's one of the real problems with it is um,
um,
what does,
what does the dude from the Chicago bears,
that famous guy,
that
quarterback from the bears fall?
Mcmann?
Yes.
Mcmahon was on the cover of sports illustrated talking about it,
but he'll be in the middle of his,
um,
his living room holding these keys.
He had no idea how it's keys got in his hand,
doesn't know where he's going.
Wow.
Where am I going?
Like,
why am I standing there holding my keys?
You just forget.
Stop.
Scary.
Yeah,
there's really skin actions.
Well,
that's why it's been so impressive that you,
with your long fight career,
you kickbox you box dude.
You know,
you had a lot of MMA fights.
I think I learned early on with the kickboxing and boxing and I looked at the
older guys and listen to them talk and went,
I don't want to be that guy.
So I started paying attention to defense.
I started watching films on great boxers with great defense,
footwork,
head movement.
You know,
all that sort of stuff and just,
and I,
and it was the key.
I never got hit with anything I didn't see.
I think you have sturdy jeans too.
You've got them.
Croatian gene helps.
I'm sure it helps.
So I'm the smallest Croatian on the planet.
When you run in,
the Croatians
are all huge,
like Cinco Cro,
cop type character,
steep,
Emile say choose a bear of a human being.
Right.
Super.
But that's just so,
have you ever seen the Olympic water polo team from Croatia?
No.
What can scariest dudes on the planet are going?
All massive.
Six,
eight guys that just will drown you.
What happened to you?
There was a time where someone claimed that you had neck surgery and you didn't
like a doctor said something about it.
I was training for a fight with frank Trigg outside of the UFC.
It was the first round warm enough and I get hit with a left hook and my neck
crunched and my left arm dropped and wouldn't work anymore.
I went,
fuck,
this just wouldn't lift at all.
It was done.
It was dead.
Kitten move your hand?
No,
everything was dead.
Wow.
So how long did that last?
It was,
well here,
I'll tell you,
that was the end of the first round.
I got cracked with it,
right?
And I go,
all right,
let's pick it up the second round.
And I hit him with like four or five,
right hands in a row.
Cause that's all I could do.
And it crushed his nose and he had to have surgery because I was so pissed off
because I,
I,
he blasted me.
Right,
right.
And I don't think it was necessarily malicious,
but we were still warming up and he cranked.
I left,
took on me,
it was bad.
So over time everything started to atrophy on this side of the body and
everything started falling apart and it was very painful.
And I went to a neurosurgeon and got an MRI.
Neurosurgeon goes,
he goes,
your spinal cord,
your,
your disc exploded.
It exploded into your spinal cord and almost separate it against the other side
of your spinal canal.
And he goes to make things worse.
You have so much to know.
So there's no fluid in there.
There's no spinal canal.
It's all scar tissue crushing your spinal cord everywhere surgically.
Right?
So you're in you.
This was bound to happen over all the years of abuse.
People wrenching on your neck,
punching you and everything else.
It just eventually gave way.
So he said,
you have to have surgery.
You're Christopher Reeves.
If you don't like you fall off,
you fall off a ladder,
you're done.
Like you have to have surgery.
And I said,
no,
I'm not going to do it.
Talk to another neurosurgeon.
He said the same thing.
Then I talked to my cousin at John Hopkins and he goes,
you're truly a moron.
You have to have surgery.
And I said,
fuck you.
I'm not going to do it.
So three guys tell you three medical experts.
So I rehabbed and like,
I got this to come back.
How'd you do it?
Um,
there was some,
some neural work by a guy at Palmer College of Chiropractic,
which is in Davenport.
He's uh,
uh,
during his,
his named Doctor Dave Journey.
He's the best athlete to ever come out of Iowa.
But he's a,
he's a genius when it comes to rebuilding the human body.
He was the strength and conditioning guy for us Olympic teams,
some of the sports and then was also on the bobsled team.
Guy Was a freak.
So what kind of stuff did he do?
He decompressions he,
he no he,
well that,
but he put me in weird positions on a table on my side and they would block
certain,
they would put pressure points to stop certain nerves from working all this
other stuff and tell me to move certain parts of my body and trying to get most
like Raul for rerouting rerouting of the nervous system and got things going
again and rebuilt me and I got to wear,
this was back to 100% it happened one other time where this side and this arms
two inches smaller than this one.
Yeah,
I could see it at,
my shoulder's gone here quite a bit.
There's some things I just can't do.
I mean I can still do pull ups in a bunch of other stuff.
There's just things I can't do.
I was wondering if my mind was playing tricks on me.
But no,
it's your right arm looks boss went through the same thing.
Right.
And this is in your neck right now as well.
They've uh,
my vertebraes fused together on their own.
They wanted to fuse them with wild.
Yeah.
Chunks of bones together on their own.
So the surgery that they wanted to do diffuse my vertebraes together,
my body did it on its own.
Right.
I've never even heard of such a thing.
Oh yeah.
You know,
long enough when the disc is destroyed and dissolves and then it just all grows
together.
So my vertebra grew together on their luck.
That's one of the craziest things I've ever heard.
Right.
So I just have to be careful listening to you.
I just have to be careful because I've been paralyzed twice from the neck down.
I got hit with an uppercut on the forehead.
Wasn't even a hard punch from Jessie Lennox.
I was sparring with Jesse before my last fight with Thomas Denny and he hit me
with an uppercut.
Wasn't even hard,
but the whiplash shut everything down from here down.
And I went ragdoll and dropped on my knees,
Jesus.
And when I was going down,
I went,
oh my neck.
And I knew that it was really bad.
And then another time I got cranked from underneath here and everything's shut
down again.
But right.
Both the cuts?
No,
this was a somebodies head was under the heck you're trying to bear hug me.
Oh,
okay.
But the,
the upper cut was right before the Thomas Danny fight a couple of weeks before.
And I went,
well shit,
I can't get hit at all now.
So I went into that Thomas Denny fight and just said,
you know,
he's not a powerhouse puncher.
I by any means,
but I can't get hit at all.
So it just danced around for the first five minutes and then knock him out early
in the second round and you know,
got out of there without getting hit.
But it's amazing the sense of urgency you get when you know you could be
paralyzed.
I wish I would.
I wish,
I wish I would have fought like that my whole career.
Right.
And then you really never get hit.
So I'm just glad my neck gave out before my brain did.
So your neck now,
how is it?
Uh,
I have to be careful.
I still have to be careful.
Have you ever thought about getting one of those artificial discs?
Um,
you know,
that do that at this point they would have to saw my vertebraes apart and it
wasn't meant for her to have them see healing up like that.
And when they will,
they sealed together on their own.
It does happen.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So when your right arm come back to a normal size,
it's been like this for years now.
Wow.
I did tons of Rehab.
This was,
how long ago did this happen?
Well,
when I was training for the frank Trigg fight,
when it first happened,
I didn't even remember again.
That's what dates,
dates are.
Just think about how many fights you've called.
Right?
Do you remember certain years of like any fight I could name or could you pull
it?
I see you as kind of a guy with a photographic memory,
so you're having things that are interesting.
It's a pretty sharp,
but it was kind of like,
that's my wife.
She was like,
this motherfucker doesn't meant shit.
Very selective memory.
Right.
But with fights,
I have a particularly good memory.
I everything to me because of fighting for all those years coaching for all
those years and doing commentary for all those years.
One big massive just fights.
Like I'll remember the huge trig fights for sure.
I'll remember,
you know Tim went on the title,
you know,
I remembered that,
that sort of stuff.
But everything else is honestly but,
or like a Jason Black who's in a war with a guy from American top team and he
comes back and he sits in the,
sits on the stool.
Some of the funniest shit I've ever seen was in fights.
Right.
You've seen it and I think you might even been calling the fight.
Jason Black sits down and it's been a war for two rounds of just insanity.
And Jason Black was a great wrestler,
just tough as nails kind of guy.
And I go,
Jason,
Dude,
stop boxing with this guy.
Let's go out.
Let's,
let's take him down.
Let's get him on his back.
Let's keep him there.
Less rough him up and let's win this round.
And we win the fight and we get out of here and he's doing this while I'm
talking to him,
he's just looking around at the crowd,
kind of like this.
And I go,
Jason,
Jason fucking look at me.
And he looks at me and he goes,
yeah.
And I go,
what I just tell you to do?
And he goes,
go out and dance with him.
And the Fertitta brothers are right there and Dana.
And they start laughing their asses off and I go,
whatever,
go out and do what you want to do.
So he went out,
it turned into a brawl.
He ended up losing the,
Jason is one of the guys,
the first guys that I saw cut weight to the point where I was like,
okay,
he might die when he went to 55 he was a fucking anatomy lesson.
You remember?
Yeah,
he sure you remember when that mother fucker had zero fat.
It was crazy.
And he was really a strong guy.
I mean he was,
I mean if he got help position,
she ate it under.
Appreciate it.
One of the toughest guys I've ever been around.
I feel like he was a tweener like maybe a little too big for 52 for seven or 50
or 70 small for seven.
Yeah,
it was a rough day or a few guys like that that would like,
you know,
real world class fighters.
But the reality of those seventies is you're dealing with guys that are cutting
from two oh five and up.
And the reality that 50 fives is that like,
that's not fucking horrible strain for your body.
I remember,
you know,
seeing guys cut weight and being a lot of trouble physically.
Right.
But our thing was always make weight no matter what.
I mean,
that's just the way it was.
I think I had one guy that didn't make weight for a fight in the IFL and he got
run out of the gym because of it.
Right,
right.
He just got run out of the gym because everybody was so pissed at him for not
making weight.
Right.
Um,
seen some horrible weight cuts with people,
but I had to wait cut where it was in New Jersey.
The weigh ins were the day of the fight.
Which fight was the Shonie Carter at continental airlines or remains for the day
of the fight that morning.
Right.
Why?
Just the way it was and the way it broke down,
the way it all went down was I had a new gym,
a Gold's gym,
building a brand new house,
had a brand new baby,
and I had to win the fight to have enough money for the down payment on the
house.
Oh,
Jesus.
They're already building it.
We already signed the paperwork and Christ.
So I'm cutting weight and I've been so busy that that wasn't paying enough
attention to my weight and I was struggling.
So the whole night I stayed awake the whole night and all I thought about was,
I know I can beat this guy.
This guy is not going to beat me.
But if he head butts me or for whatever reason,
and I don't win the fight and lose that money,
I lose my house.
Oh my God.
I start to panic.
Right.
And when you're cutting weight like that,
it's,
everything's magnified a hundred times.
The,
the,
just the fear and everything else.
And all I thought about was that water and egg white or a scrambled eggs all
night,
the whole night.
And by the time it was time to weigh in,
I went and knocked on Matt Hughes and Jens Pulver his door and I go,
hey man,
I'm in some serious trouble right now.
I'm I,
because I sucked on ice cubes all night and I gained like two pounds or
whatever.
So I had to go cut again.
What?
I just don't wait just from sucking on ice cubes all night.
Two pounds of ice cubes,
I guess.
Yeah,
because I didn't even know where I was at.
I was losing my mind.
Right.
Wow.
So I did that all night.
And then,
so I made weight and then I went back to my hotel room and I started cramping.
Everything cramped.
I at the time,
my wrestling shoes on as tight as I could possibly tie them so my feet wouldn't
bend like this.
Right.
Whoa.
And then my cat started cramping.
Everything cramped to the point where I was curled up in the fetal position and
I knew I had to fight that night.
Holy Shit.
So I couldn't see.
Right.
There was a bunch of stuff going wrong with my body.
So I called up Monte Cox in his room and I go,
you got to get somebody to take me to the hospital to get ivs.
Are the shifts not happening?
He goes,
all right,
I'm sending Tom Sour.
Right.
So you remember Tom's house?
Yes.
So Tom's hour comes to get me and everybody who knows,
Tom knows he had really severe Tourette's,
right.
Really severe Tourette's.
Like if he's around black people,
the n words getting yelled constantly,
right?
Uh,
yeah,
he's around women,
these yellow and hunt whore bitch,
bitch,
bitch.
But it's worth right the whole time.
Really loud.
So anyway,
he comes and gets me.
He takes me to the hospital.
We're walking up to the hospital in New Jersey.
The whole hospital is all glass windows.
Everybody that works in the hospital is black.
Oh No.
Imagine the kind of situation I'm in mentally and physically.
And I stopped and I put my hand on his chest and I go,
Tom,
you can not go in here with me.
Oh my God,
you're going to yell the n word a million times.
They're going to kick us out.
I'm not going to get my ivs right.
I'm not going to be able to fight it.
I'm gonna lose my house.
I was like,
I was losing my mind.
Right.
And he goes,
pat could kick it.
It's okay.
Chirp.
Chirp,
click,
click.
Right,
right.
He goes,
it's fine.
I'm a Dade county paramedic.
He goes,
I deal with this constantly.
It's okay.
So we walk in,
we go up to the nurse at the reception desk,
and he goes,
hey.
He goes,
my friend,
click,
Click Edward Edward,
Edward,
and she,
she looks at him and goes,
say what?
And he goes,
I have Tourette's.
I have severe Tourette's.
Please don't.
He goes,
my friend needs an ivy badly.
And she looks at me and goes,
oh shit.
Like I looked that bad.
My eyes were way back in my head.
I was in rough shape.
So they gave me three liters of saline,
three liters.
Yeah,
revived me.
And like a two liter Pepsi,
that was three of us.
Three of those three,
three,
one liters.
Yeah.
That's a lot of water.
Right,
right.
And so they revived me enough.
I was still seeing double when it came fight time.
And so the first round I just took Shoney down.
I threw him,
took him down,
stayed mounted on him the whole first round to get him to wear himself out with
punches,
elbows,
just stuff.
Just not going overboard.
But I wanted him to be tired going into the second round.
How diminish to you in this state?
Bad.
Yeah.
It was bad.
Like half,
half year capacity maybe.
Yeah.
So the second round I just went,
okay,
now I got to end it.
So I just,
I had kicked him and knock him out.
I remember that and I just went,
I made it out of that with the skin of my teeth.
Ooh.
You know?
But so it's just weight cutting can be very extreme.
Yeah.
It really can.
But we always believed in that you have to make weight,
then you sign your name.
And that's why I get so pissed off and disgusted when people don't make what.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a lack of discipline for sure.
If,
unless it's not physically possible for you to make the weight.
Like if you're a heavyweight and you want to make lightweight,
that's not physically possible.
Right.
So then don't sign it.
It's a lack of commitment.
See,
that's the thing that I,
I'm disgusted most with,
is that people don't,
aren't committed to what they do.
Right.
You've obviously committed to what you do.
You're very good at the things that you do,
right?
It is,
it's obvious.
You're obviously a talented guy,
but you work at your craft.
Right?
You know,
there,
there came a time where I had to leave college,
just go home and take care of my alien mother and had to work three jobs and
realized sitting in a basement that that was raised in every time it rained,
it flooded.
My feet were in water.
I woke up one morning and that was doing,
you know,
I had started out fighting and everything and I said,
this is it.
I'm going to win a world title.
I mean the winning the UFC title,
what's it?
This is it.
And I loaded a nine millimeter pistol and I put a round in the chamber and I put
it in my sock drawer and I said,
if I don't want a world title that Gun's going in my mouth and I'm done,
this is it.
Right?
So every time I fought,
I thought about that gun in my sock drawer and not wanting to go home to it.
And that's just,
that's commitment.
That was my,
that's what was needed for me to succeed at that point in my life.
That's the way it was.
So when I see people not when they're talented and they're not committed,
I don't want anything to do with them.
I just don't,
I don't have time for people like that.
I'll take a guy who's committed and sucks and training every day.
Right.
Because I love his commitment.
Well,
there's some guys that just make some real critical errors,
but they're incredibly talented.
Like Norma Gum head off.
Like,
you know,
when he missed fight the fight with Tony Ferguson,
he literally,
his body was shutting down.
They'd had to take him to the hospital.
I'll comes to preparation though.
She didn't red haired better.
Yeah.
He should have gotten lighter beforehand.
Should've watched the Diet.
Now that he has a nutritionist,
he made weighed pretty easy for his last fight with Barboza and now he's going
to be fighting for the title and the guy's a monster.
He's a fucking monster.
Yeah.
But you know,
aspirin had a real good point.
Uh,
what they do with one fc I think is the way to do it.
You know,
with one FC,
they test you,
they have a hydration test and they test you and whatever weight the champions
are,
they just bumped everybody up a notch and they bumped him up to one 85.
Yeah.
He'll like,
there's no cutting weight here.
And I think that's just an unfortunate part of martial arts is this weight
cutting shit,
wrestling,
boxing,
this,
think about,
you know,
they complained about the,
the fighters cutting weight.
That's for,
you know,
three,
four times a year.
Really not that hard.
Right.
Try cutting weight your entire life every wrestling season.
And when you Russell during the winter,
then spring,
summer for freestyle and Greco.
Right.
That was probably the thing that made me so small compared to my brothers.
They were all six,
four,
six,
five sure is.
I cut weight from sixth grade all the way through high school and into college
and then fighting.
Right.
So my,
during my growing years though,
I was starving.
Right.
That's just the way it was.
And so it stunted my growth most likely.
I'm sure it did.
Yeah,
there was,
I knew a lot of guys from wrestling that were like that.
The brothers were big and they were small,
but I think that it's just unnecessary for MMA.
I mean,
you're dealing with professional athletes at the highest level of the game.
I think they should just cut it out.
I just think they should implement going to happen though.
Everybody's going to look at the drive.
See if they do the one FC rules.
They test you three times.
They test your weight,
they get a base weight off of you.
They get hydration levels.
Everybody has to follow that same look.
Everybody has to follow the Usada rules.
I don't think,
I think the,
the,
the rules like in,
in reference to guys using performance enhancing drugs,
it's just as critical to keep guys from fighting dehydrated or from being
dehydrated.
Now it's,
I mean obviously there's risks.
Yeah.
Fighting dehydrated.
You saw the,
which boxing,
which boxing match was,
it?
Was it
got a little Italian dude got the hell beat out of him.
Was it,
um,
who fought ward three times and wars?
Micky Ward and Touro.
God,
daddy fought a little Muchow.
What it not come out.
Mosey Macho fuckers is named Kitty from Maine.
Louis domain,
but erected it destroyed him cause he was so much bigger than that.
So that,
you know,
there's risks obviously.
So who was that
put pull up our Touro Godaddy's professional record.
Yeah,
he would think I remember that.
His,
his name was Joe who was from Lewiston.
Maine is a talented guy and Arturo Gotti was looked like he was two weight
classes bigger than him and he fucked him up.
But yeah.
Okay.
If you've got a peek ahead,
is he writing it down?
What would he got here?
Um,
you just had to go way back now we alive.
Joe Camacho.
I needed a bucket.
Joey Camacho.
That's who it was.
I remembered that.
That was horrific.
That was 2000 man.
Time flies.
How crazy.
Cut.
Melted.
Tough guy.
Can't hold his piss.
Now we know.
That's probably why I had a hard time cutting weight.
It doesn't make any sense.
Um,
pull that fight up.
I'm gonna see that fight and make you a Arturo Gotti.
Joey Camacho.
That was a disturbing one.
The thing is like you see so many of those kind of Kaos in MMA.
It makes you realize,
yeah,
our two of God,
he was just far bigger than him in this fight and he was also,
this is Arturo Gotti when he was really world class two at the top of his game.
What they're working on a movie or something.
Well,
you know,
he was killed by his girlfriend and just killed by his girlfriend.
She got away with it or his wife,
his wife was this Brazilian chick and she got out of jail when she got out of
jail.
She was smiling.
It's really disturbing.
He got clipped there with a left hook.
It was real bad.
Like,
um,
they think that
there was some severe,
oh,
there's the KL.
They think there's some severe uh,
corruption involved in her,
uh,
her acquittal,
cause she got acquitted in Brazil and they said that he was,
he committed suicide,
but he had some sort of blunt force trauma on his head.
It was a,
it was a big deal and it was very,
it was very sad for a lot of people that were Arturo Gotti fans because
his fights with Micky ward were,
there's fights where guys are matched perfectly,
where it's like their skill level.
We're talking about a Turo Gadi and Micky Ward and how God,
he was a pat Miletich returns from the restroom.
How God he was,
um,
killed by his girlfriend or his wife.
Right.
And acquitted.
She was acquitted and it's like pretty obvious it's someone murdered them and
they pass it off as a,
uh,
as a suicide and then because of domestic or something.
No,
no.
She fucking killed him,
man.
And when she got out of jail,
she was smiling.
She's like,
she's like taking,
they're taking pictures of her leaving jail.
I think there's just a Brazil job.
I couldn't you no corruption in Brazil is bad,
is bad.
I mean,
they tried to get rid of the fucking president recently.
Right?
I don't know what happened with that.
They were just stealing money,
period.
Right.
There's some severe corruption in Brazil and apparently in this case most people
think that she killed him and that she got away with it.
Yeah.
To get an understanding too of the Brazilian people,
you have to read a book called um,
to Guerrero.
Never heard of that.
No,
I saw the city of God though.
Yeah.
You want to understand fucking Brazilians.
Watch that movie.
City of God.
I've never heard of it.
Holy Shit.
It was just tell me about this movie.
And so ultra,
ultra rare or to Guerrero was a book about Sasha and Ernst Simmel to Russians
who had engineering degrees who went to Brazil around 1920 1921 during the
diamond rush.
Right.
And this was when,
ironically I think when the,
the Gracie started learning Jujitsu,
right about the same,
about the same area.
So Ernst and Sasha [inaudible] both were catch wrestling guys and boxers and it
just tough Russians,
right.
We know how tough Russians are.
So anyway,
they are working their way through Brazil and through the Mato Grosso,
stopping at ranches and towns fixing guns.
Cause the Brazilians didn't know how to fix our guns to pay their way further in
as they were getting towards the rivers and all that sort of stuff.
And to find diamonds is that that was our thing.
But during all of this,
uh,
Sasha semel was fighting,
no holds barred fights against Paraguayan strong men and all this sort of stuff
in,
in the ring.
And then he became a guy who was what's called a to guerrera guy who can use a
spear and kill one of the big cats in the jungles back then that was killing the
cattle,
killing the ranch hands,
all this sort of stuff.
These are 400 pound cats,
right?
These are big scary panthers in the jungle.
So he went and sought out and found a,
a Indian or Brazilian Indian who was supposedly
a,
took rare the expert.
And he found this guy and the guy's just drunk,
just completely drunk.
And he goes,
I want you to take me and teach me how to do this.
And so they go and the guys drinking the whole time and he goes,
they run across a big cat.
And what these cats would do is riflemen on horses would go track the cats,
the cats would double back on them,
take them off their horse and kill them,
right?
So they were killing rifleman.
So these cats were smart.
So this guy taught him though.
He watched this guy drunk kill a 400 pound cat with a spear.
And then he taught him how they would sit on their paws,
whether they were going high to attack you,
whether they were coming low,
how to position the spear,
all that sort of stuff.
So,
uh,
Sasha semel became a white guy who'd killed 33 big cats for ranches,
right?
Why this beer?
Yeah,
it's the coolest.
It's the coolest,
but you couldn't write it any better.
But to tell you about the Brazilian mindset,
there was a guy in one of the,
uh,
gun Smith blacksmith shops where they were fixing guns for people that this one
Brazilian had an attitude and Sasha insulted him in front of the friends.
So this guy,
then once you insulted Brazilian back in those days,
especially,
they have to kill you because you disrespected them so badly in front of their
family and friends and that that's,
they're just hot blooded people,
right?
You've been around enough resilience.
They're hot blooded people,
a Vandelay Silva when he loses his temper,
and it's a pretty scary dude.
So this guy tracks them for awhile and then they hire a guy that's the sheriff
of Pasa Fundo who has a necklace of human ears to prove he brings back the ears
of the person you paid him to kill,
and that's how he got paid.
Right?
So he had a necklace of human ears and he was hunting Sasha,
or it's,
it's the coolest book you've ever read.
Wow.
It's incredible to her,
to Grerrero Tig,
r.
E.
R.
O,
but it's a rare book.
A friend of mine,
Amsti Tig,
r e R.
O.
R.
Two Guerrero.
It's a rare book.
It's hard to find,
and John Wayne was going to make a movie about it,
but they couldn't do the movie.
They were going to do it in the 50s or whatever it was,
but they couldn't because the Amazon was still too dangerous.
There's cannibals everywhere and all kinds of stuff and you know,
malaria and everything else.
So they,
there's actually a documentary about going there to do the site surveys and all
that sort of stuff.
And they went,
you have malaria and South America?
I think so.
It's not,
malaria is just an Amazon in the Amazon and stuff like that.
Right.
I'm sure they've got plenty of diseases,
but yeah,
the cannibals,
that's like what got that,
that explore that English explorer and the lost city of Z.
Right.
I,
I've never heard of that.
Yeah.
The Lost City of Z is a book that they turned into a movie a couple of years ago
about this guy and it turned out that what he had discovered has now been proven
that there was some ancient systems.
They're a,
some ancient,
uh,
civilizations,
civilization,
but also irrigation systems.
And they've,
they've figured out that they had all these roads and stuff because of satellite
imagery there and some new technology where they can look through the bushes and
all the,
the jungle foliage and stuff and these and
roads and everything.
Dude,
that's,
yeah,
there he is.
That's him.
Is that a spear right next to him?
There's pictures of gunner,
a spear gun with a bandit on it.
Oh.
But there's pictures of him with spears going up against cats to Jesus Christ.
Dude,
he was hardcore,
man.
There's this beer that's a spear,
but it's a fucking animal.
Jesus cried.
That's so crazy.
I think about that.
I spoke to his son.
I was,
I was writing the screenplay on his life.
Wow.
And I talked to his son,
Sasha junior about it.
And um,
he eventually just didn't want to do the life rights thing and all that.
And what if the eight though the Jaguars,
I have no idea.
Do you know mountain lions?
Delicious?
Is it?
I have people that say so.
Their favorite food.
Really?
Yeah.
I had no idea you could even eat it,
but it's apparently a more delicious version of pork.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be fantastic mountain mine loin,
like the back loin.
Backstrap a mountain lion.
A mountain lion.
Yeah.
There's things I'll eat and things I won't,
I don't know if I'd eat a predator.
I eat the fuck out of a mountain line.
Yeah,
like them.
Yeah.
When I'm killed my dog when I lived in Colorado.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I've seen,
I've seen two of them.
I saw that one and I saw one of them in Santa Barbara.
Oh,
it's actually driving through Monosito real nice neighborhood,
and I saw this thing run across the road and at first I thought it was a coyote.
Then it saw the tail and I went,
Oh shit,
that's a cat.
Wow.
Then I realized it was the mount cat.
Not that big.
No.
50 60 pounds.
There's obviously some massive ones out there.
Fucking giant ones.
Yeah.
Colorado's got some fucking whoppers and the coyotes,
the coyotes where I live there,
they're everywhere.
You ever see the picture of the one we were supposed to get that whatever
happened with that,
the one,
the Hollywood sign with the cat,
with the,
the,
we were supposed to buy that.
I need to get,
I found the place to get it.
Yeah.
Let me,
let me read it.
Visit that and buy that thing because there's an iconic photo to me that just
symbolizes our intrusion into the wild world and the consequences of it.
There's an enormous cat that lives in the Hollywood hills and there's a photo of
him.
Look at this.
This is taken by camera trap.
This is a real photo.
Wow.
This fucking cat got tags on it.
You got Colorado them.
They know the cat.
I had a,
I forgot the guy's name.
The gentleman that we talked about the other day that was,
oh,
the,
the ranger was explained to us how they do it.
They have to dart this fucker every couple of years when the chase battery's
dead.
Yeah.
So every couple of years,
this guy goes into fucking dreamland,
like George Saint Pierre.
And uh,
I lost the time and comes back.
Oh,
there's him with a deer.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
It's like digging a hole,
I guess.
Now the coyotes are ruthless.
Where I live,
man,
they're everywhere.
They're fucking everywhere.
When killed my chicken just two days ago.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I have chickens.
It was,
uh,
I was out in the backyard.
So the jump on the roof of the chicken coop and then jump over the top of the
fence.
There's so graceful though.
They're smart.
It's all so smart.
One of my,
one of my good buddies who,
he sold his company to Orkin,
so he was an expert at getting rid of deer,
getting rid of Coyote's,
getting rid of anything off your property,
getting rid of raccoons out of your house,
whatever.
Right.
He's,
he's the guy that started trapping when he was 10 years old.
Right.
And some of my buddies did that and he was one of them,
but he became the expert,
sold his company to Oregon for a lot of money.
But he is the first and foremost guy besides one other guy,
I think world worldwide that is the expert in trapping coyotes.
And when he explains it to you,
you sit there and go,
how smart are these?
And if there's anything out of place,
they never take the same way back to their den ever.
They always go a different route.
They're smart about covering their tracks and to trap him.
He goes,
if you do one thing wrong,
they,
they recognize it right away and they're gone.
So he had to go and really study,
research and disagree years by Dan Flores.
It's called Coyote America.
And uh,
Dan is a,
he's a professor at,
I think it was he from university in New Mexico.
He's from New Mexico,
genius guy.
But he went into great detail about how intelligent these fucking things I about
how native Americans used to think they were gods.
They were tricksters and they're basically wolves.
There are small wolf.
Miniature,
yeah,
yeah.
They're just a miniature,
super intelligent.
And I,
my old house that I had that had some timber on it and stuff.
I had a fox down across the creek on the hillside,
the five watts,
a hawk,
Fox coming back with squirrels and rabbits every morning at four or five when
that'd be up to get warm,
get workouts in,
they'd be drinking coffee.
I'd have Turkey vultures on my frigging Turkey.
Vultures are this big man.
They're massive.
And they'd sit on the railing of my,
my pad,
my porch outside.
You know,
my,
I hear my wife scream,
just shriek and go,
Jesus,
I go,
what?
And she goes,
what the fuck are those things?
And then she not from around there?
No,
she's from Montreal.
A first language is French.
He was a city girl.
All that sort of style that he brought it to ILS while she was studying to be a
doctor of Chiropractic and in,
uh,
at Palmer,
which was in Davenport,
Iowa.
And uh,
so,
you know,
the thing is though,
I had eagles,
owls,
hawks herds,
a deer,
coyotes,
all kinds of crazy stuff running through my yard constantly.
And that's when I had the mastiff and a and a shepherd and some other stuff
that,
uh,
you know,
my master for one of the killer,
everything that came into my heart for sure a big ass dog like that.
I was the,
that's like one of the best places in the world for whitetail deer.
They're huge.
I have a buddy of mine,
my friend John Dudley,
he bought a farm out in Iowa.
Just a hunt whitetail.
Yeah.
So the,
the military farm is down in southern Iowa and my grandma on the other side,
her farm was down there also.
And it's,
you know,
obviously a lot of timber also,
and it's the deer you see down there.
And even,
you know,
in Bettendorf Iowa where I live,
which is right next to the Mississippi river,
the deer are huge.
I see a deer in Texas and they looked like a German shepherd.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
right?
It's,
you know what that is?
That's the warmth and the porn principle.
There's that too,
as corn,
soybeans,
all that sort of stuff.
They're well fed all the time.
And they,
uh,
did I hit a deer?
What was it,
a year and a half ago with my F-150 and all it was,
was his chest hit the front quarter up front of the quarter panel and scraped
down at and destroy the whole side of my truck.
Just destroyed it.
They're that big.
They're tanks.
Yeah.
Now imagine hitting a moose.
My Dad hit a moose almost killing Jesus.
It,
it,
uh,
the vehicle caught on fire because the moose crushed into the engine compartment
and caved in the front of the vehicle and then it all caught on fire.
And my dad had the to and go out the kick the back of window off to get out
Jesus Christ.
And if you hawk it a moose,
if you stop and then Hawk it a moose,
I'll kick your ass.
They'll run in and smash your car.
Yeah.
So you've just seen a moose.
I went on a fishing trip,
one of the many fishing trips I went on in Canada with a friend of mine,
Mark Lewis,
and we were in a v bottom boat.
There was three of us and we were going the English river system,
if you ever want to go fishing in the summer for bad ass fish,
I mean you'll,
you'll wear out catching fish up there.
It's north of lake of the woods and we were going across the lake and the
English river system is massive and it's endless amounts of islands.
You can get lost really easy up there.
But we were cutting across the lake and we got into this bay and there was a
moose swimming across the band,
you know the huge rack on it and everything else.
And my buddy mark goes,
pull up next to it.
He goes,
yeah,
just pull up right to its ass.
And so I pulled up kind of just on its ass and he jumps out of the boat on its
back.
Oh no he did.
So He's,
so he's riding on the back of the Moose and the Moose was doing this,
trying to get to him and finally he jumps off,
climbs back in the boat.
We turned away and write down the moose hit shallow ground and came up right
after he would have been dead.
He would have been dead.
Big fucking animal.
Yeah.
They're one of the rare deer species that almost regularly charges people.
They fuck people up.
All the things run into Duluth,
Minnesota in downtown and smash everybody.
Yeah.
They just stomped people in,
in Alaska too.
And it's usually the problem is if you find them a female that's with our babies
are done,
that's when you're in real,
real trouble.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
So do you hunt much?
Yeah,
a lot.
Yeah.
Where do you,
where do you hunt usually?
I've hunted in Iowa hundred Iowa for whitetail last year.
Um,
he's outside of Des Moines.
Okay.
About like a 45 minutes outside of the morning.
Um,
I hunt Utah.
I shot an elk in Utah this year.
Um,
I got,
uh,
another elk and um,
central California.
Um,
I tried to go to as many places as possible.
I'm going next month I'm going to Lanai for access deer,
mostly bow hunt during most of the cool.
Yeah,
I love it.
Got a hell of a bow,
a hunting thing set up in the air.
Yeah.
It's pretty bad back there.
45 yard indoor range.
It's cool.
It's good.
Keep practice.
The doctor that I told you about,
Tyson Cobb,
the orthopedic surgeon that fixed him,
his arm,
he was a bow hunter who went and got crocodile in Africa,
you know,
big old giant games,
stuff like that.
And um,
you know,
the stuff that he haunted was,
I mean,
you know,
killing a grizzly
with a bow is some scary stuff.
Yeah.
That's a real risky proposition.
But he did,
he did stuff like that.
Yeah.
My friend Dudley that I was telling you about that lives in Iowa,
he does that too.
He goes all over the world and,
and hunts you miss.
Yeah.
It's very,
very risky.
Very risky.
Right.
But you know,
it's,
the thing about the grizzly hunting is like,
people don't like it.
Like it's gotten to the point where in BC they've outlawed it,
right.
And,
uh,
they really shouldn't have.
And the reason being is that you've got to control the populations because
there's nothing that eats them like except them.
They're all cannibals.
All Grizzlies,
all,
even black bears are all cannibals.
Sticky.
The cubs,
the cubs all the time.
And if one of them dies,
like if you,
I've been black bear hunting before and if you shoot a black bear and like maybe
you shoot it like right before dark and it runs off into the Bush camp,
they don't want to go after it.
You come back in the morning,
bears are eating it.
Yeah,
they eat,
they eat their own.
I've just been a guy that,
you know,
I don't have time to hunt.
I,
I've gone deer hunting a couple times.
I just never,
you know,
I'm more of a fish.
I love to fish.
I do too.
Right.
So that's my fishing.
You do.
I'll fish for,
you know,
I've fished for shark off a beach before.
That's another thing that people get mad at it.
They get mad if eat sharks now.
Well we let them go.
We let them go.
You know,
that's not,
not a big deal.
But I watched a guy from black barks,
uh,
tackle company.
They taught me how to do it off the beach.
These guys are catching 14 foot hammerheads off the beach.
Dude.
Do you know one of the best places to hunt to fish for sharks rather is off of
Catalina or right out,
right out of your wife?
No,
for a Maaco.
Okay.
It's like one of the best Maaco Shark,
which are massive.
Huge.
Yeah.
So,
but they taught me how to do that.
I love fishing for Barracuda,
just cause they're so aggressive.
It's a fun fish.
Oh my God.
They're scarier than hell.
As fast as they hit a lure.
It's crazy.
But crazy looking at,
and I love Musky Pike fishing bass fishing.
Say they look like a pike on steroids.
That's what they are.
They're the sea water fish.
Oh yeah.
Muskies are awesome.
So I went musky fishing at the [inaudible] Indian reservation.
It's the Chippewa flowage where the biggest muskie in the world was ever caught.
Right.
Really?
How much is that a 67 pounds Saturday?
One thing,
I don't know,
but it's,
it's huge.
It's huge.
Coyote size.
But they've found jaws and teeth of muskies that are twice that size,
right.
Just washed up on shore type stuff.
So there's huge muskie still.
But the guy that took me fishing,
he took a job.
He used to work in Vegas for the casino down in Vegas.
I forget which one.
And he left that and went back to Wisconsin,
northern Wisconsin because he wanted to muskie fish.
Right.
So he took a job with the Lakota Indian reservations just so he could musky
fishing and he was the vice president.
Oh Shit.
Look at the size of that.
Fucking their tear.
They're terrifying.
Right?
It looks like a person that's like a person the size to fish.
That's,
that's less than 60 pounds.
But those will,
those will attack you.
Oh yeah.
They'll attack you there.
That I knew a dude who invented a lure.
Um,
do I know him?
I know his friend.
I don't know.
Anyway,
someone invented a lore that was a duck.
Yeah,
it was a 15 my grandpa used to fish Tom with ducklings.
You Hook them through the tail and throw them out on top of the lake and let
them swim around in a Musky would hit him.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy how the ducks,
yeah.
So this guy had a allure,
well,
you can ask on Youtube play.
Then as you read it in the paddles,
the feet would move and the Musky would think it's a real duck.
And they jack.
Yeah.
So they,
but the guy that was the,
he was that casino guy that took me fishing.
What do you got here?
Jamie called a suicide duck.
Lewer oh,
so,
okay,
so nice.
See,
this is my fishing days or a long fucking time ago.
Yeah.
This is like when I was a very early teenager,
like 1314 I was so connected to fishing.
I fish constantly.
I still fish.
I still love it,
but a,
I'm out of the loop in turns of like that.
This is a regular thing.
So this is a duck also.
The duck is like,
he's running away
at a Musky,
comes in Jackson and make him look panicked,
right?
Yeah.
But the,
he was the vice president of the Musky World Association and he took me fishing
and he goes there,
we have tons of muskies that we've radio tag.
He goes,
but we're not going to use that.
That's cheating.
I know their patterns.
Anyway,
tag a Musky.
They just put punched the thing by the Dorsal fan and it's got the little,
gives out a transmitter and you know,
you can find out their patterns or whatever.
But he goes,
I'll take your Musky fishing tomorrow if you want to go.
I said,
yeah,
awesome.
So we go to the bait store and he gets chubs this big.
That's the bait.
So you're holding your hand out about a foot and a half there,
at least 1214 inch fish,
right?
That's the bait.
Right?
And he'd hook 'em through by the Dorsal Fan.
We'd go out in the boat,
drop the Chub straight down,
then we'd go back to the island and he had a rod holder,
put the pole in there,
set the drag,
real light,
put a Bob at the top of the line so you could see the bobber move if something
was taken off with it.
And we did that four separate times with four lines.
And then we sat in the boat and ate sandwiches and just talked and then all of a
sudden the bobber takes off and he goes,
all right,
I'm going to pull up you run and grab the pole.
Jumped back in the boat.
He goes,
I'm going to maneuver you and keep you.
You have to stay over the top of the fish and with Musky trolling motor scare
him.
But a regular boat motor island does not for some reason.
So I'm learning a ton of stuff from this guy and he goes,
we have to for 25 minutes.
You have to let him turn that fish head first and then swallow.
That's the rule about 25 minutes.
It takes them,
they take their time,
they wait till it's dead,
they crush it with their jaws and they slowly flip it and then they swallow it
and he goes,
but if it starts to run anytime before that,
you have to try and set the hook.
That's just the way it is.
So,
and this is my first time Musky fishing.
When they start chewing on them,
you just wait.
Yeah,
yeah.
You stay over him.
But so the,
the Musky will be swimming a size that fucker.
Yeah.
So there'll be swimming along.
So somebody caught that,
caught that bass,
right.
Then the [inaudible] got a hold of that.
They just have the Musky.
They just have the bat.
Right.
So you've got to let them turn them and then set the hook.
Then you'll catch the Musky.
Right.
But so that's what we did.
And at about 17 minutes it took off,
started to run.
I set the hook and I caught a 52 inch musky first.
Oh
yeah.
Holy Shit.
I felt like I set the hook in a log.
That is a big fucking thing.
And I really cool stuff.
The two inch Musky man.
Yeah,
they're a northern pike.
Fishing is very fun.
I've done that in Alberta.
Some of my favorite times.
They hit hard.
Yeah.
And so the English river system where we used to go,
if you catch up,
you know a pike this long,
you leave it on the hook cause a big ones common.
Right.
And then the first time it happened to me,
scared the living shit out of it.
So when you catch a pike that's two feet long and you just leave it on the hook,
let it swim around up there anyway.
And you're just hoping that no you're not.
It's common.
Wow.
Yeah.
So a big one.
This one here.
Yeah.
Watch
fucking cannibals.
Cannibals in the Goldwater world number babe.
Winkelman the professional fishermen shore.
This one is right there it comes and he's just holding it over this bigger one
that's underneath it.
There's such a crazy animal too,
like pike seen prehistoric and they are cannibals without a doubt.
Yeah,
Babe Winkelman.
I watched the video while I was in Canada fishing.
We were at the lodge and Babe Winkelman is asking this guy who's a an Indian
guide.
He goes,
so what do pike?
And the guide goes,
pike the Pike.
And he goes,
no,
what to Pikey?
He goes,
Pike like they breed.
So they have food.
That's what they eat.
It's just they're just aggressive.
Mean Fish.
Yeah.
And they live in that dog eat dog cold water environment where there's three
feet of ice above them half the time.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Well all those animals up there like,
look,
we're talking about bears.
Have bears being cannibals and hike,
being cannibals and the fucking deer,
350 pounds.
It's just a tough hardcore world.
Yeah.
I mean when it gets that God damn cold,
it's a tough world.
Then you go to a whole nother level and go to places like Africa and Australia
and it's hot.
It's another world too.
Everything's deadly in Australia.
I wouldn't even want to live there.
That's right.
Adam Green Tree.
Listen to Pat Miletich,
my friend Adam who shot that a water buffalo head in Australia,
keeps trying to get me to go down there and hunt with me with him.
And he's,
every time he sends me pictures of spiders kill you,
a lizard that can kill your own snakes.
Yeah.
Everything.
Everything kills centipedes and they have these gigantic 2000 pound buffaloes
that are super hyper aggressive and they're roaming around smash you.
They will,
they have to kill them though.
That's another thing.
It's like the grizzly bear thing.
They don't have predators,
you know,
in,
in Alaska,
but they're herbivores.
So they're kind of meant to be handed in my mind.
Yes,
I agree.
But there's nothing to hunt them out there.
Right.
The problem with Australia is that these are invasive species.
I got pretty much everything over there.
So the ranchers brought them there or something for someone brought them there a
long time ago.
New Zealand's the craziest place because New Zealand is essentially,
uh,
they,
they set it up as a wild game park for rich a year,
Europeans long time ago.
And so now they have these enormous stags and all these huge animals that live
there,
but no predators.
So sometimes they have to thin the herd,
they have to fly
over with helicopters and gun him down.
Well,
they hunt.
I mean,
we're allowed,
they made a rule in Bettendorf,
Iowa within city limits.
You can hunt deer with a bow.
Yeah.
Within city limits because there's just so many of them.
You'll see a herd of 50 of them.
They do that in Pennsylvania too.
Okay.
Yeah.
There's a lot of places where they just get so overrun that they have what they
call urban hunting.
Yeah.
But people set up,
tree stands in their backyard and you know,
uh,
as far as the fishing goes,
you should go noodling,
noodling for catfish.
You got to bite your hand talk that,
that seems so stupid because occasionally you fuck up and get a snapping turtle.
Right.
Or beaver.
Beaver.
And that's a beaver that can shoot down a tree.
Magic what it do to your wrists.
It would hurt.
Definitely.
I did at one time and that was,
it went noodling one time.
I actually got lucky.
Yeah,
I got it.
Yeah.
It was like 14 pounder,
you know?
But when they snapped on your arm,
it scares the shit out of you.
Oh,
I'm sure right now,
what is the idea is that the catfish thinks you're intruding or they think it's
a fish.
All they do think it's our hands,
a fish,
and they get to see your hand is bait.
Well,
fuck that.
I like fishing poles.
I like to be in a boat or on the shore.
I like all the,
all the sophisticated intelligent things.
Yeah.
So I was going to ask you,
how's it,
how's it been working with Jimmy Smith?
I love that guy.
He's brilliant.
He's a very smart,
trying to get him hired about four years ago.
And it was because the UFC was looking for God,
first of all,
trying to do last commentary because I was traveling too much and I was trying
to do last time I was like,
you got to hire this guy.
He's the best.
He's really,
really smart.
I love first we're doing our first show together in April,
the Tony Ferguson Habib number of Madoff.
Oh,
good,
good.
Yeah,
it could be.
Versus Tony's going to be,
it's a perfect fight for,
you know,
whose color and play by play then is he doing play by play and you're doing
color?
No,
John Annex doing play by play and Johnson.
Awesome guys both doing color.
We're just going to have fun.
He's our friend,
you know,
and he's been on the podcast a bunch of times.
Right Buddy?
So it'll be,
it'll be a good time.
He cut his teeth doing a TV show about combat sports.
More about,
he did [inaudible] around the world or whatever.
Learning different arts.
Was it called fight support?
What was it called?
Something like that.
Fight quest fight.
It was,
yeah,
he did that.
But I mean I think he's,
but he also had MMA fights and he's a legit black belt in Jujitsu.
He's no,
he knows this stuff.
Super Smart and well read guy too.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm excited.
I'm excited that he's on board.
Yeah.
I always liked listening to him.
Bella tour fucked up.
They fucked up and they left.
I couldn't,
I was wondering what,
so what,
what?
I'm not to Pry,
but my guess was he just asked for more money probably because he has an offer
from the UFC,
they wouldn't match it.
So he took,
well,
whatever,
they didn't want him leaving for the UFC four years ago when I tried to get him
hired.
Right.
And um,
there was like a big hullabaloo and they wound up keeping them.
And then I think his contract was up and I think the way he described it was
they actually wanted to give him less money.
He was getting,
and I think they're just experiencing some severe budget cuts.
If you think about Bella tours market,
like what they're trying
to do,
they don't have a paper view business.
Right.
You know,
and if you don't have a paper review business,
where's the bulk of all your money coming from?
It's like kind of bleeding Viacom.
Right.
I just thought,
you know,
when it happened,
I said,
why didn't they change the name when coker was brought in to takeover?
Yeah.
It made zero sense to me because Bella tour had that,
you know,
from Bjorn Rep knee.
I've never been to Bjorn revenue fan Bjorn revenue from that boxing promoter
type,
you know,
whatever it was.
And everybody that I talked to in that,
in that business,
they were all terrified and intimidated and everything else.
A lot of shit.
Yeah,
it was just a lot.
I never met the guy.
I don't know anything about him other than the bad things that I've heard from
fighters.
Right.
And so you know,
King Mo calling him a Dick Rider,
kick low king king,
King Mo and I go back and forth on,
on the Internet,
on Facebook and stuff.
I'll deliberately piss him off on po political stuff and just get him,
get him,
get him Sunday or appreciated talent when it comes to fighting.
No,
he's a,
he that guy was a monster.
Physical problems though.
Like with the Mercer,
he had some serious staph infection.
Right.
Some real bad ones that wrecked him.
That fucking shit scared.
He's a great guy though.
We talk,
we talk now and then when I see a good stuff he has,
he's cool dude.
And uh,
but uh,
God,
where were we when we were talking about,
but we should have changed the name.
It's just synonymous with tournaments and the guy loses a title and suddenly
he's thrown back into a tournament.
He's already made his name.
It's just a shitty business model.
And Bella Torah was for the Spanish speaking crowd,
right?
Isn't that what they were trying to get out of that whole thing word right?
I think it's or Roman word for gladiator or some shit.
But yeah,
it started out as,
um,
wasn't on like ESPN Deportes or something like that,
but it just didn't make sense with coke taken over.
And I don't want to watch the Geritol posy fight.
I don't want to see a pap military flight.
I don't mind.
I want to see Ya.
Right.
Everybody's,
you know,
I love some of those guys,
but I don't want to watch it.
I agree.
It's,
you know,
it's a young man's sport.
It's guys that are animals,
fast movers,
just yeast,
invincible human beings in their mid twenties to thirties early thirties I guy
that's 45 years old.
I just,
just,
just 45 but 45 years old with MMA miles on them.
Yeah.
That's the real issue,
right?
It's that these guys,
their bodies have been beaten up for so many decades in the gym and all the
years of wrestling and kickboxing and yeah,
they're just not the same.
No.
Yeah.
It takes its toll.
It definitely takes its toll and you're just not,
you're just not the same.
I mean,
there's part of me that respects the shit out of a guy like hoists.
Gracie is still a fucking savage.
If 50 years of age ready to throw down with anybody,
he wouldn't fight me.
He wouldn't sign up.
When was this?
I've been trying to,
I,
I mean with Bella tour,
I said pricking,
get Gracie to fight me.
When he was fighting Shamrock,
I confronted shamrock on access.
That was one of the worst fights that I had passed.
When Matt beat the Shit out of him,
Matt took his back,
was smashed him and I was like,
Jesus Christ.
I was like,
this is,
this is so mismatched.
So the voices in a different era and Matt is,
even though Matt's not ranked,
he's a legit blackbelt right,
right.
And a stud wrestler and a physical freak,
an end super experienced with modern high level MMA hoists was living in the
past.
And the thing was with that,
that was after rob Lawler worry mark on myself,
Tim Silvia,
Gann Mcgee,
Chuck Lidell,
all of us were on that movie set in Mexico,
that Paul Walker film.
Okay.
Right.
Paul was great guy.
He's,
he was legitimately a good human being.
I'm sure you knew him and all that.
She doesn't know him,
but I heard the stuff,
the stuff that he did on the set to stick up for the small guys was incredible.
Maybe we got time to talk about it,
but not,
we're not.
But,
um,
we had gotten done with that.
We'd become friends with Paul Walker and Oakley Lemon,
who was his stunt double for everything.
And,
um,
the stunt guys were all really cool with us.
We kind of gravitate towards them because there's stunt guys when we're
fighters.
We got along really well with them,
but Laurence Fishburne was on the set,
the Keratin brothers,
you know,
I'm a kid from Iowa going,
this is fucking awesome,
right?
These are,
these are cool too.
Sorry,
just to be around these guys.
But um,
so they were all at that fight in La and Paul Walker and all his actor buddies
were in one row,
right behind them was Oakley lemon and all his stunt guys.
And so Paul Walker was a Gracie Jujitsu student.
He loved that.
And so they were cheering for voice.
All the stunt guys were treating from that.
They're the hardcore,
like,
you know.
So anyway,
Matt just dismantles it rex and completely,
and I turn around,
I'm up on the deck outside the cage and I turned around and Paul Walker and all
this actor buddies are like the US like Holy Shit.
Like,
I can't believe this just happened standing on the chairs.
Behind them is Oakley Lemon and all the,
all the stunt guys going,
yeah,
military.
That's awesome.
It was.
It was,
but I saw half that crowd crying.
Yeah.
Cause they saw a god get destroyed.
But I mean this is a hero to hoist is like for martial arts.
He,
he was a legitimate hero.
He was the first guy to win the ultimate fighting championship.
And the way he did it was like,
Whoa,
look at this.
These guys using technique that we didn't even know exists.
Little skinny guy.
There's just mainly people.
And the thing was with all of that,
you know,
then the Gracies came back with Hughes was just a better athlete and used all
Jujitsu,
Gracie Jujitsu to beat Gracie Jiu Jitsu.
So I went through all the stuff.
He hit a duck under on hoist when hoists tried to hit him with an elbow.
The road,
it's like hitting with a half Nelson when hoy started regained guard,
when Matt took his back,
that was just a bunch of wrestling mixed in there.
Right.
And so then they brought out Alomeda.
Now,
Meda was their dog to come and beat Matt.
Right?
So they put in Alomeda who was bigger than that?
You know,
he's a big dude for that weight division.
Well,
Matt deliberately hit him with a wrestling front headlock and choke him
unconscious.
Well,
it was a position that a lot of Jujitsu guys are used to being in there and they
just relaxed.
They're waiting for you to spin
to the back,
but instead of spinning to the back matches,
crank that sucker down.
When you shut off your stuff,
the head under the armpit and you crank that down and then twist it,
crushed it.
You just get,
you get choked.
That's all there is actually a gorilla like Matt.
Right.
And so when they did the interview,
you were probably the guy doing the interview and he goes,
he goes,
you know,
it was just nice to use wrestling on a Jujitsu and to cut him unconscious.
Not just yet.
I don't think Ricardo knew that that could put them out.
Right.
You know,
I mean a lot of us have been in those positions before,
but it's usually a transitionary position where a guy turns and gets you back on
like no one's ever done it since either,
by the way.
No,
no one's ever talked to the guy on the wrestling.
Guys in wrestling,
we'll use that stuff.
You know like Dave little bitch who wrestled for Purdue,
Dave and Julie A.
Little bit,
Jay,
we're all Americans at Purdue and they were beasts and obviously little bitch.
They were Croatian psycho correlations in Michigan City,
Indiana where they grew up and little bitch used to use a move that they named
the little bitch where it was a,
you'd include what the fuck is the name of it,
not a Doris,
but Anaconda.
Anaconda.
It was an anaconda in college wrestling and it looked like you had a front
headlock and he would choke people unconscious.
As soon as they'd go lip,
he'd grab the chin,
roll him and pin him.
Ah,
he was doing that with Turner about that Dave Little Bitch pin bill Tate from
Iowa state.
Bill Tate was a Waterloo,
Iowa guy and he put them asleep.
He put them asleep and pinned him in the,
in the NCAA championships.
Is that illegal?
Oh,
it's totally illegal.
But referees didn't understand it because it looked like you had the arm
included in the headlock.
Right,
right.
But if you do have an arm included in a headlock,
well is it your fault if the guy goes asleep?
No,
none at all.
But see what it is when he go to pin him,
if the referee recognized he went limp,
they would stop the match for a potentially dangerous hold or whatever she'd
have to do is get some of these really bad UFC referees to referee wrestling and
they would have no idea who that guy was that.
Yeah.
But there's guys doing the juicy at the NCAAS,
the guy hitting the key lock on the guy trying to break his arm.
No.
Yeah,
didn't I'm Mark Schultz do that in the Olympics.
All,
you know,
I'm not sure if the guy's fucking arm off with that.
Uh,
I believe he's disqualified.
I mean the Schultz brothers were just scaring and Dave Schultz was unbeatable
animals.
They were trying to build people to beat him over in Russia.
When Ma,
remember when mark fought,
he fought big daddy Goodrich,
truly Marette rag doll.
But then in the movie they had,
they used a different guy.
They didn't have him fight in big daddy Goodrich in the movie.
They had him fight some Russian.
It was at Fox catcher or something.
It was a bullshit scene.
I was like,
why would you do that?
This is actual real history.
You really have a guy who's like one of the best wrestlers to ever fight in MMA.
To us,
it was a real historical moment and he took it on last second notice.
He fought big daddy Goodrich.
We all remember it.
But in this fucking movie,
you faked it.
You put someone else in.
So what else did you fake?
The bullshit was in this movie we are pretending this is a historical recreation
of a real national crime that everybody heard about.
It was a real tragedy and it was a tragedy against a guy who was one of the best
wrestlers that America had to offer for.
I felt,
I felt like it was one of the worst examples
of what Hollywood does.
The arrogance of Hollywood due to a real story,
a real story.
They just decided,
fuck big daddy,
good rich.
Why have him in there and would be like Mike Tyson pretending Mike Tyson won the
fucking world title against Ivan Drago or something.
Really,
it would be something everybody knows what the real fight was.
You know,
being an Iowa Guy,
this whole California experience and Hollywood and all this stuff freaks me the
fuck out.
It should.
It does was just some I,
I was out here pitching TV shows before the ultimate fighter.
I was pitching on ultimate ultimate fighter show to Kevin Riley,
who was the president of NBC at the time,
and John Hirschfeld,
who you know,
right?
John Hirschfield goes,
look,
you're going to have maybe five,
10 minutes with these people,
right.
I had them laughing for an hour and a half and they're like,
this is awesome.
I love this show.
I love this idea and mine was much different than the ultimate fighter.
Right.
It actually made sense.
The four pillars of MMA and competing in each one and all that sort of stuff.
Right.
Well,
he called us personally and he goes,
you know,
the board talked about it and the board just,
he goes,
I couldn't get it through.
They just don't feel mainstreams ready for this type of thing and all that.
Then the ultimate fighter came out on spike and the rest was history,
but every time I had one show sold to stars,
the guy that used to be the president of the Hbo,
I remember him.
Which guy?
The guy that got in trouble,
right?
Yeah.
I can't remember his name now off.
I remember Brett Rhett know rex now I can all Breck.
Yeah,
Chris Albrecht.
Chris Albright.
That's it.
I had a show sold and then they were going to co brand it with Spartacus and
then the lead actor from Spartacus got terminal cancer and they couldn't cope
random together and that deal fell apart.
Then another one that I had sold fell apart because of the collapse in 2008 and
I was like,
dude,
I can't win anything.
Like deal set business.
Also like if you're an outsider and you're coming in here to try to pitch
things,
there's so many people they already know that they're pitching things,
right?
Like you got to imagine if you're a guy that's a producer or you know,
uh,
an executive rather at some sort of a network,
you've got people knocking on your door all day long.
You're used to quality from certain people or when you want to see you've seen
their work before.
It's very hard for an outsider to get in.
Oh Dude,
I finally just went,
yeah,
I had so many concepts written on a laptop.
I'd sit up all hours of the night writing concepts for shows,
all that sort of stuff.
This thing that you're doing for fun,
you're a conspiracy farm.
That's probably your best way in podcasts are the best way in because the build
an audience and undeniable audience and we want to go to,
you know,
black sites,
CIA,
and,
and arrest us and drag our ass in there.
Right?
We want to get in trouble,
right?
And we want to go to places where we don't want that.
We're going to push say you'd want that.
You don't want that?
I don't.
Okay.
I get what you're saying.
But we want to push the envelope,
right?
We want to push the envelope when we want to.
We want to expose the real facts behind what's really going on and that would
cause some heat.
I'm sure that we eventually get a call.
You know where you need to kind of divert off the path you're on without a
doubt.
You look at forward to that call.
Are you starting to do a show like that?
I did Joe Rogan questions,
everything,
but mostly it was on big foot and Ufo stuff.
You're not going to get in trouble from aliens,
right?
Well,
it was mostly almost all bullshit.
That's the problem.
And I was much more interested in conspiracy theories before I did that show,
but in the six months that I did that show and all these different people that I
interviewed and all the stuff you saw in the air,
it was just a fraction of the total mass of all the people that I talk to mostly
was bullshit.
Mostly is crazy people.
Most of these people that just have a bad way of looking at reality,
like they're there.
They have confirmation bias and the way they look at things,
they just have this very distorted version of what the truth is.
And they also want big foot to be real.
They want aliens to be real.
They want the government to be spraying shit out of planes above us all the
time.
It's all just,
but we've had,
we've had Brennan who was head of the CIA admit to that though,
at least.
Well,
they admit to one thing that they have looked into weather modification,
but the idea that every fucking south west flight is spraying aluminum and all
this different shit in the air.
No,
for sure.
They've experimented on using it for warfare.
I mean,
they've looked into everything.
They've looked at [inaudible] house,
fear over your enemy,
your enemy,
and have storms breakout on them.
There's that.
And also to,
uh,
look,
you know,
in Abu Dhabi,
they make it rain every week.
They make it rain fell two times a year.
Yeah,
just do it with,
they just throw money in the air and it fucking rains.
Like they just figured out a way to cloud seed and that cloud seeding has been
around forever.
That's real.
Yeah.
But that's not what you're seeing when you see planes fly overhead and you see
those clouds that form behind the planes,
that is a reaction between the jet engines,
the condensation in the atmosphere,
the heat of the jet engine.
And that was never sold on it for a long time.
I was never sold on that at all.
It's ridiculous.
You know,
I was never,
you know,
and the,
the nine 11 conspiracies and stuff like that.
The only thing that I've noticed about that is you can see the detonations going
off on building seven when it never got,
you don't see detonations when you see soft floors collapsing and the pressure
of these floors collapsing,
causing these windows to blow out,
right.
This is just what would happen if something was paying scribe to it,
is what I'm saying.
I don't know what you're saying.
I don't subscribe to it either.
I mean,
who knows what the fuck happened with all the shit behind the scenes.
But what we do know is that a bunch of people capitalize on that,
which makes it look like conspiracy.
All the intelligence reports that came out before that happened was that the
terrorist planned on using planes as missiles to take down building.
We knew that at least that's where I stopped.
I lean much more towards incompetence than I do.
Massive conspiracy.
A bunch of Barney fife,
keystone cops.
That's what I think.
But who knows.
Um,
I wanted to talk to you about marathons,
about ultra marathons.
Like you,
you
got into,
uh,
when did you start getting into this?
It was a couple of years ago,
John Byrne,
who is a professor at a college in my hometown and he and his family had taken
martial arts from me for years and he one day walked up to me,
I think it was 2012 or earlier,
and he goes,
hey,
he goes,
I want to thank you for all the confidence you've given me.
And he was an amazing guy,
very,
very smart guy and a great athlete,
great basketball player.
The guys now 53 years old,
I think,
and never gets hurt.
He can do anything he wants and he does not get hurt.
He's just a genetic freak,
right?
But he comes to me and he goes,
thank you for giving me the confidence.
I love the martial arts training,
but I'm going to try something new.
And I said,
what are you going to try?
And he goes,
this thing called the Leadville 100.
And I go,
what the hell is that?
He goes,
well,
it's a high altitude,
a hundred mile race through the Colorado Rockies.
And I go,
how many days is this supposed to take?
And he goes,
oh no,
you do it all at once.
You're going to do a hundred miles without basically stopped.
And he goes,
yeah,
he goes about every 10 miles,
you get new food and fluids and you just keep going.
I went,
awesome.
Go do it,
man.
And he went and he finished.
He barely barely made the cutoff,
which is 30 hours.
You have to do it right.
And so I thought,
this is really cool.
And it was a couple of years ago where he sent me a message and he goes,
I'm training for Leadville again.
I go,
maybe it's a good idea for me to jump in.
I want to do something extreme.
And since I quit fighting,
I couldn't ever find that was just that void in my life,
right.
And my health was deteriorating.
I couldn't figure out how to get back in shape because,
um,
I was in pain constantly.
I had asthma,
all this other stuff.
I found out that that was gluten,
the gluten problem.
Right.
And I thought before that I thought,
if somebody says I'm gluten sensitive or I have allergy to gluten,
I go,
whatever.
What is gluten?
Right?
But I was running into so many physical problems.
I started training with these guys and I'd be crippled for two,
three days.
I'd be in so much pain that I couldn't do anything.
And then my buddy goes and I was getting ready to eat,
start eating oxy cottons.
That was,
I mean,
I could survive on Motrin,
all the pain,
everything else.
But I got to the point where I flying.
I'd walked five gates in the airport and have to stop and sit down.
I was in so much pain.
My arthritis was just horrible.
I'd be soaked in sweat,
everything else.
So I had all these problems and I figured if I train with these guys,
it'll bring me out of this,
this point in life,
and it will change my life.
And I'll get back to the,
you know,
pat mental chip of the old while I was falling apart.
Worse because of the intensity of the training.
So my buddy did blood tests on me.
He goes,
you're going to be dead in three years from a heart attack.
There's so much inflammation in your body.
If you don't stop eating gluten,
I go,
what the Hell is gluten?
He goes,
wheat and soy.
You have to stop eating where you're dead.
He swings gluten.
Yeah,
wheat and soy.
So it's all about how,
wait a minute,
I thought it's all modified grains.
Soy.
Soy has been modified,
like black beans have been modified for a certain amount of time.
Your body doesn't digest black.
Black beans really like a waste of time to eat.
So,
but the,
the wheat and the soy is what was causing the inflammation along with the
spraying that goes on with wheat and soy fields.
It's really bad,
right?
Yeah.
So anyway.
Yeah,
it's bad.
Bad stuff.
So anyway,
he said you'll be dead in three years from a heart attack.
There's so much inflammation.
You have asthma,
you have three forms of arthritis,
your digestion system,
your digestive system is destroyed.
He goes,
how's your temper been lately?
I go,
not real good.
He goes,
your brain's getting destroyed.
Your thinking process is screwed up because the chemicals that your stomach is
given off is affecting the way you think.
It's your second stomach or your second brain.
Right.
He goes,
so you have to understand that.
So I quit cold Turkey,
stopped eating.
It took about a week before my arthritis subsided.
Started to go away.
I went from running three mile runs and feeling miserable for three days to 10
months later.
I did a 75 mile run in 10 in 10 months though from,
from not eating that garbage it was it a race,
the 75 mile run.
It was actually a training run.
It was a training run with the guys and that we,
you know,
they,
they worked me up from um,
you know,
three mile run,
10 mile run,
12 miles,
1518,
20,
you know,
drop back down to a 10 mile run on the weekend.
They'd always do the long runs on the weekends.
And a lot of times I was doing these runs on no sleep because I'd done a
broadcast Friday night,
get home,
get home the next day on Saturday,
half,
no sleep because you know,
you can finish late and you got to fly home first thing in the morning is what I
always did,
operating on no sleep and then start and we'd just 30 mile run 35 45 50 and then
a 75 mile run along with the stuff,
training during the week that a lot of it I was doing on the road too.
And it's just an amazing group.
It's probably the coolest group of people I've been around.
And David Clark,
who is a guy that served as a role model for me just reading his book,
which is called out there,
ultra recovery it guy that was 320 pound alcoholic who changed his life one day
and decided to become a bad ass ultra runner.
Um,
it just,
being around those people,
they,
they don't show pain.
They don't,
they just don't show pain even when they're in misery.
Um,
it's,
it's a weird mindset.
It's,
it's so much different than MMA where 25 minutes of misery and exhausting fight
is.
Now that I've gone through some of this stuff,
it's,
it's a joke.
It's a complete joke because when you're out there running 75 miles,
50 miles,
I ran 50 miles in 97 degree heat with the same percentage of humidity on a
blacktop country road in Iowa.
Getting scorched went through probably four hours of heatstroke.
My brain was getting cooked.
I mean,
I literally felt like I was,
I could die at any time and these guys are laughing at me.
They're laughing.
They had me in a field at mile 30 a farmer's yard hosing me down with cold water
from the farmer's house just to get my body temperature down so I could get
going again.
Right.
Wow.
Just crazy stuff like that.
They're,
they're just hardcore to,
it's amazing group of people and I encourage people to work their way up,
try and find a running group and try it because it's,
it's cool shit.
How often you do it now I backed off of late.
I've been doing more,
kind of getting back into grappling a little bit,
doing a little bit of kickboxing,
grappling even with your neck.
I tell people,
look,
don't go for the gold.
You know,
and I had to tell the grant and there's a lot of good grapplers at the place.
I go to a summit,
it's a wrestling and Jujitsu facility.
Crossfits in there,
a bunch of other stuff.
But some of the guys that I used to train or the senior guys down there and
there,
there's some really technical guys,
some 10th planet guides.
Actually Joel Loughlin,
uh,
follows,
follows that system quite a bit.
And he's,
he's former special forces guy.
And you know,
I just said to everybody,
the first few times I went down there I go,
look,
I have no desire to be a world champion again.
I've been paralyzed twice from the neck down.
I have no desire to get into frigging brawls with any of you.
I go,
I'm here to get back in shape and just grapple and kind of fun again.
You know what I mean?
So let's,
let's understand that.
First and foremost,
if you go for crazy submissions on my neck,
I'm not going to like you a whole lot.
So,
um,
so I'm doing a lot of that.
I'm slowly getting kind of back into the mindset of ramping back up with the
running and stuff like that.
And my brother who's 58 who never ran,
he did Leadville last year.
Was it last year?
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
that's a guy that never ran and most people take their lifetime to be able to do
a marathon.
He did 50 miles at Leadville,
missed the cutoff at 50 miles,
but he's 58 years old and never ran before and just he was in love with it.
He fell in love with it.
He's in the mountains,
you know,
I already live my sports streams.
Joe.
I already won a world title.
I've done some cool shit.
So to me running that,
when I saw the course and went,
this is,
this is intimidating,
this is to look at a mountain and no,
you've got to go over it at the 40 to 50 mile mark and then 50 to 60 going back.
Cause it's some scary shit.
It's intimidated.
My brother was totally the opposite mindset.
He was like,
this is the coolest Shit I've ever done in my life.
He doesn't bomb and down that mountain was the coolest thing I've ever done in
my life.
This is amazing.
And I just went,
that's the way the mind supposed to work for stuff like this.
He got it.
You know what I mean?
So well it is a lot of it is how you approach things.
Right?
And how you approach challenges.
Like some people love the idea of something being very difficult.
Like what a struggle.
I can't believe how tough that was.
You get out of it,
you feel exhilarated.
Whereas other people they look at it like,
oh no,
I need a couch and a beer and a sandwich and a good TV show about fucking,
you know.
Right.
Whatever.
But I did,
so I did Leadville a couple of years back and John Byrne and I went out two
weeks early and I had to leave from Colorado,
fly back to providence to do a broadcast and then fly back.
He picked me up at the airport and we went back up.
But while I was with him for the first couple of days,
we went out up Mount Elbert,
which is the tallest mountain in Colorado.
And I felt the altitude,
I felt the alligator 14 five or whatever it was.
And it was,
it was painful on the way up.
And then we got caught on a storm on the top of the mountain,
a bad storm,
hail downpour and lightening hitting everywhere all over the mountain.
We had the bomb down this mountain as fast as we could and I trashed my quads.
Right?
And we're real close to the actual race at that point,
right.
It's like a week and a half away.
And so then I got on a plane,
flew to Providence,
and I was panicking.
I was like,
this is some serious shit I'm about to do.
Right?
And I started sweating.
I'd never had anxiety attacks before in my life.
And I'm like,
what the fuck are you thinking,
dude,
this is some crazy stuff.
And so I,
we were getting ready to go live and Michael Chavela looks at me and he goes,
why are you soaked?
I go,
I'm fucking freaking out,
dude.
I got to fly back to Colorado.
Go do this race.
I'm panicking.
Right?
And I never thought I'd be afraid of anything but that the course is that
intimidating.
Right.
So Michael Goes,
dude,
relax.
It's okay.
So we did the show,
everything I got back there and it,
you know,
when you're out there in the mountains,
you start at four o'clock in the morning.
And these,
they're just,
they're hardcore runners,
man.
They're hardcore bad assets.
People.
You'd never,
if you looked at them on the street,
you go,
there's no way that person could run five miles.
And they're just smiling for a hundred miles.
They're just going,
going,
you know,
so Courtney,
Courtney doe,
Walter is,
right,
right.
I had her on and she wanted the Moab to 40 by how many hours she beat the 10
hours and 20 miles.
She beat the second place guy.
That's amazing.
Were there people that thought she cheated to do that?
Nope.
They newer.
Everybody knew her.
She's an animal.
She,
she won a race blind.
She was having some sort of retinal edema so she couldn't see anything but her
feet [inaudible] had to tell her where to go and all that sort of stuff.
She had a pacer.
She tripped and fell and cracked her head open.
She,
she went through the finish line.
Bloody and blind.
That's the toughest stuff.
And that's one of the toughest people you're ever going to meet.
Right?
Right.
If you met her completely unassuming,
thin woman,
real silly drinks,
beer and eat Nachos,
not on some kind of crazy die eats candy.
Right.
She's real fun to hang out with.
That's like very easy going.
That's like you meet Navy seals and you go,
they're supposed to be tough.
Right,
right.
But I watched navy seals fall apart last year when my brother was doing the
race,
like just fall apart.
Just Whitley.
Yet.
Just like,
well,
if you're not physically prepared to wow,
you know,
they didn't,
I know that some of them did the 50 miler out there.
Right.
So they were getting ready for it.
But you know,
the,
you get dehydrated at any point or caloric deficit or all this,
these different altitude problems that can come about all the other stuff,
you know,
it's,
it's uh,
it's definitely a mental thing that,
yes,
it's wild.
So fighting is the way I look at it.
The best way I can explain to you as fighting is so fucking easy.
Finding the Harrison.
Yeah.
I mean,
in reality,
I mean I was fighting like when I fought Palae when he was ranked second in the
world,
I was ranked first.
I didn't train for six weeks for that fight cause I was crippled,
right?
I was injured,
low back,
destroyed,
all kinds of stuff.
I had 12 shots as Aila came into my back to go out and fight.
He's crying and he was the number two guy in the world at the time and very
athletic,
a fucking killer at the time.
But he couldn't do shit to hurt me.
Even when I was crippled,
he fell back for a leg lock on me and I laughed at him and he was like,
well,
that's not going to work,
so let's get right.
But he was hanging on my head and I'm throwing up her cuts and body shots and
he's plumbing me.
He ran up my body with knees like that,
you know,
just a freak.
But fighting is that easy.
It's that simple to me because you're trying to outwit now smarter than other
human beings.
Right?
Right.
When you're running for 50 miles,
75 miles,
whatever,
a hundred miles you battling with yourself the entire time.
Yes.
That's where you get mind fucked.
Right,
right,
right.
That's the scary part about it.
Cause you gotta face yourself.
Yeah.
It's a different thing.
You're,
you're in.
You're in the middle of a fight,
especially a war.
You're in the moment you're throwing bombs and acting and reacting and just
doing it and dealing with it and toughen it up.
You take a minute break,
drink some water,
hop right back out again for five minutes.
Is it just a completely different animal?
Right.
You do you miss the old days of no time limits.
Uh,
I had fun back in those days because I could go a hundred miles an hour in gas
people out and beat them.
Right,
right.
With the conditioning.
I enjoyed that.
I did.
I did enjoy that.
Um,
but you know,
it is,
it is what it is.
It's the,
there were fights in tournaments that would go 45 minutes and just show you
can't cover that on TV.
Right,
right,
right.
We just can't keep,
he fought Dan.
Was that a no time limit?
Third argument,
that one round fight.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So it's just,
it is what it is.
People,
people would sit down and watch it live,
but they're not going to watch it on TV.
Even though you're going to pay for,
for you get bummed out.
Right.
It's just not the best thing.
In terms of entertainment value.
No,
not at all.
Not at all.
So it's,
you know,
the rounds,
the rules,
all that sort of stuff.
That the way you look at some girls in bikinis is in between rounds.
Walk around with the cards.
You know,
I talked to John Perretti,
we had John Perretti on one of my podcasts actually.
Yeah.
How's he doing?
I know he's got some health issues,
you know,
I think he's,
he's,
I know he's got the MS and some other issues and stuff like that,
but,
um,
you know,
he,
he wants people to know that he's the guy that did that.
He did.
Right.
He wants people to know I'm the guy that frigging created all that stuff.
Well,
he was the matchmaker at the time when I first started working for the UFC in
[inaudible] 97.
Okay.
And um,
so it has been since 97 you were involved?
Yeah,
I did UFC 12.
That's awesome.
Okay.
Yeah,
that was the,
and I came in at 16,
so you've been around longer than me.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I remember your debut.
I remember when I was,
um,
I remember Mikey Burnett.
How's he doing?
He's doing,
I think.
Okay.
I know he got shot,
right?
Yeah,
the robbery.
He was a good guy.
Tough motherfucker.
I remember when he fought Eugenio to Dale and rectum rectum when everybody
thought that he was the next guy.
Genio was a psychopath.
Friggin went after hen zone was kicking handles ass and they shut the power down
in the building,
so hands up wouldn't lose.
That was in Brazil,
right?
That was crazy.
It was back then.
Yeah.
But Burnett was,
Mikey Burnett was a guy who was a Greco national champ.
Benched four oh five squatted four oh five stronger than shit.
Toughest fuck.
Yeah,
yeah,
the old days.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
It's been so long.
It's really interesting when you stop and think about it,
how many thousands of flights with you called?
I've seen way too many people get fucked up.
I know that.
I'm real numb to watch it.
People get beat up.
That's my,
and that's the thing.
That's too,
I would say as my coaching career progressed,
as I got older,
you know when you're young and you're full of testosterone in near a psychopath
and you're coaching,
it's just,
Oh,
let's go do this.
Right,
right.
And as I got older and mellowed out,
I mean I had to lay down on the floor of the locker room before the first Hugh's
trig fight.
Cause I knew Trigg was a dangerous dude,
just a tough son of a bitch and a good wrestler.
Right.
And I was really nervous for that fight.
I had to lay on my back and just decompress for 30 minutes before that fight
just to go out and just coach with,
you know,
with a car mine,
and,
and uh,
you know,
when he was fought Carlos Newton,
after Carlos took the title from me and Carlos comes out and we were infuriated
because he's walking out with two playboy bunnies and you know,
acting and that was,
you know,
it's a show,
right?
It's a show.
It's how it was when that big ramp.
Right.
And so he was standing there and I was all pumped up and I was like,
Matt,
you know,
we had to get mad off a tractor on the farm to come and fight him.
Right?
Cause my automatic rematch clause got,
they reneged on that and say it's your choice.
Either Mac and fight him or somebody from another camp.
But if Matt or somebody from another,
if somebody from another camp fights,
I mean you've got the winter no matter what.
But if Matt fights him and loses,
you can,
you can rematch Carlos.
But if Matt wins,
obviously that's Kinda tough cause we're buddies.
Right?
Right.
So Matt standing inside the cage and I'm pumped.
Absolutely pumped.
I go,
you got to smash this guy.
I'm screaming.
And it was,
you got to fucking smash him.
And Matt turns around and he goes,
it's going to be okay,
dude.
All right.
He goes,
we got this dude,
we got this.
I was like,
all right.
That was a crazy winter.
That's when he slammed him with a triangle.
Yeah.
The entire crowd.
Their mouths were hanging open.
They'd never seen anything like that.
And they're like,
well was he kinda half out?
He was out triangle.
He was just out with the triangle.
[inaudible] was going out and slammed him and then went out.
Here's the thing,
that's why he jumped up and said,
I want Matt.
No,
Matt sits up like this and he's kind of looking around and I dove over the cage
and my let my legs catch on one side so that that could barely touch Matt's head
with my hand.
And they scraped his hair really fast and I'm like,
get up,
get up.
I knew he was out.
Right,
so get up,
get up and he stands up and he goes,
what happened?
And Jeremy Goes,
he's just one of these like
crazy.
That was cool.
That was a cool fight.
Yeah.
Very intense.
Yeah,
that was very intense.
Carlos Newton was one of the most technical Jujitsu guys.
Oh yeah.
He was very athletic dude.
Yeah.
One of the best sites I've ever seen to this day was he and Dan Henderson.
Oh yeah.
That was an insane fight.
Yeah,
those guys are great fight.
That was 97 [inaudible] 97 and possibly somewhere in that era.
That was one of my early days.
I remember when Chuck Ladell made his UFC debut.
I think he fought noe Hernandez and appreciate he's wearing wrestling shoes.
No,
he Hernandez trained with me for that fight.
And no,
he got hurt before that flight.
I can't remember what he injured,
but no,
he couldn't train hard for that fight.
So he wasn't in great shape.
But he was knocking the shit out of chuck until he ran out of gas.
I mean he was boxing Chuck's ears off,
knocking down a flight.
Peretti came to chuck and told them if you want to keep working and to keep
fighting for the UFC,
do not take this guy down.
Oh really?
Yeah,
because they found out the chuck was a wrestler.
Ah Wow.
This,
those are the dirty days.
That was a Gary shot.
The Gary Shaw,
him,
Petros Ellian sharematch type stuff.
Right.
Petros only had to stand up with Kimbo cause he replaced shamrock.
Aw Man,
I forgot about that guy.
One of the greatest interviews ever was Dana white after that.
Remember when he looks at the camera and he goes,
you can't do that.
It's book and that's fucking illegal.
Yeah,
it is fucking illegal.
That was the dumbest matchup to when I,
there's a video of me in the green room of the punchline in Atlanta,
Georgia.
I had gotten off stage and I was waiting to see Ken shamrock fight keep Kimbo
okay.
And I was like,
what a fight this is going to be.
I get off stage and they say,
oh,
Ken shamrock got hurt and warming up and Kimbo is now fighting Seth Petras
Ellie.
And I go,
oh,
this is a terrible idea.
Fucking and I said it and I said to the camera,
it's like the craziest thing ever.
I go,
Seth Patch jail.
He's gonna fuck him up.
I'm like,
this is,
we're assuming he's going to take him down and submit it.
And He,
I thought he was going to KLM.
Seth was way better striker.
I thought something was going to take him down.
I thought Seth is a karate striker,
like at legit season black belts.
Right.
And,
and,
and uh,
he could submit guys,
but he's just a,
he was on another level as a mixed martial artist.
I was like Kimbos ineffective.
So here's me while this is happening,
if I'm wrong and never see this to go to the beginning,
hold on.
It's what it said in the beginning.
Fuck Kimbo slice.
This is a last minute replacement.
I got to take set parts.
Set purchase though.
He's gonna fuck him up
if I'm wrong and never see this.
So it happens in the green row in literally the fight is six seconds long.
Well
that's it.
You look older.
There was a beard.
I had that full beard back then.
That was after Evan died.
Whenever Tanner died,
we all grew beards.
Ah,
yeah.
Yeah.
That was a bad deal,
man.
I'm sad.
Very bad.
Yeah.
That guy was,
um,
I think he rolled out there into the desert.
It was on a mission,
I think might have,
you know,
I mean maybe when he was out there he decided to go that way.
Or maybe you just really did get lost and couldn't find his water.
But that's one of the hottest places on earth.
Yeah.
I mean he gets to the one thirties and stuff.
It's just not,
that was a bummer.
It a bummer.
He was a great guy.
He's an interesting guy too.
You know,
he was,
I got,
I really wasn't into the money.
Really wasn't mean.
He was into the journey and difficult quite,
he probably would've loved the ultra running.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And he fought down.
What was the show in Texas that they were doing back then?
Cause he cut his teeth in that circuit down there in Texas.
I can't remember what shows those.
Remember he fought checks is fighting championship or something.
He was a tough motherfucker man when he fought Dave Turrell.
Oh yeah.
I mean Dave Terrell had them in a guillotine,
wouldn't tap and then he starts smashing them and that,
that's how he wanted to try was talented.
Fuck.
Yay was,
but he was mentally like he would fall apart.
Right.
Well he did in that fight,
or at least he gassed out.
You know what,
something happened in that fight.
But yeah,
that was the word is that his talent never matched up to his performances.
And as a Jujitsu player though,
he was very,
very successful.
Like I,
I saw him fighting Abu Dhabi.
Who's a fucking [inaudible] man.
I mean he was phenomenal and to this day produces some of the best black belts.
Who's the best grappler on the planet now?
You think?
That's a good question.
It's hard to tell.
I mean,
it's probably Danaher's guys.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's probably Gordon Ryan or maybe Gary Tonin or one of those guys.
Right.
But then there's a lot of really high level Jujitsu guys.
See,
the thing is these,
no one has caught up to Donna hers leg game.
Like,
um,
there's a few guys,
there's Craig Jones out of Australia that's on a real high level.
There's,
there's a bunch of guys that are closing in,
but it seems like what Donna is doing and he,
I mean,
Donna her is such a fucking wizard.
He's such a genius in his application of his mind,
you know,
cause Danaher's severely crippled.
He's got a one fake hip and they're gonna,
they're gonna replace one of his knees.
And he hurt his knee a long time ago from a rugby accident and they,
his knee was so loose and fucked up,
but they shortened his tendons to stitch them back together again.
But they shortened them too much and he never could fully extend his leg.
And he was fucked up from then on out.
And then it's caused by a defect in his hip because Lord,
yeah,
I wore out his hip so he's severely injured.
But his mind is a genius.
I mean he's just very,
very,
very intelligent guy.
Superior intellect and his,
the way he's applied like that thought process to Jujitsu is just incredibly
unique.
And so those guys,
Eddy Cummings,
Nikki Ryan,
Gordon,
Ryan like this,
this Donna,
her death squad,
what they call,
I have to think that at least in terms of accomplishments,
I mean that guy submitted a Cyborg Ricardo a brew.
I mean fucking easy if you watch that fight.
And I had um,
John Danaher on the podcast breakdown what he did to Cyborg.
Cyborg is a multiple time world champion and Gordon Ryan went right through him
and Gordon Ryan 22 years old.
Yeah,
I think somewhere around there.
I look at it.
Good,
great.
Grapplers throughout history from back the early Gracie's,
you know,
the foreign law burns,
all these scary dudes and stuff.
And as it moves forward in time and just watching guys how they,
it's almost like a constant cyclical,
there's a cycle there of you.
You learn how to defend stuff,
you hit stuff,
people learn how to defend it and you move on.
And it's this constant cycle of it and the new shit coming out and creative
stuff.
And I just watch it evolve and go,
man,
I just,
I wish I could stay young forever just along with it.
You know what I mean?
With your body.
Yeah.
It's,
it's an unfortunate thing that your mind,
he absorbs all these techniques and you understand how to compete better,
but your body just gives out.
Right.
And that's the thing with the MMA especially,
I think it's a race to amass enough knowledge to one a title before the body
gives out.
Right,
right.
Well that's why TRT was so interesting,
you know,
like the TRT v toward days because you had v toward choose to the tits.
And with all that experience,
I mean,
veto made his UFC debut back when I called my first fight and it was when I was
a post fight interview or rather UFC 12 that was his debut at 19 years of age.
So here you had him at 37 juiced out of his fucking mind with muscles on his
eyebrows.
I mean he was so jacked when he fought Rockhold when he fight Bisbing I mean
clearly he was not just taking testosterone replacement therapy.
He was juiced up.
I mean he was way above normal levels.
I remember UFC Brazil,
I was fighting Vandelay and veto.
We're fighting each other.
Yeah.
Right.
And you knew that was a collision.
Yeah,
that was too scary dudes.
If he told her shoes for that fight.
But here's the crazy thing,
I'm in my locker room and I'm getting ready to fight and one of the tours
trainers comes in via tore,
sent them to get me to come give him a pep talk.
Whoa.
That was the fight when he had hid for like three days.
Cause he was terrified.
Fatty Lou was so scary.
He was having,
he was having just this I think a mental breakdown,
uh,
an anxiety attack about fighting veto or about fighting Vandelay Silva.
So he's in his locker room and he's sitting in the corner and he was light with
his eyes big.
He's scared to death.
And I walked in there and I'm like,
dude,
fucking,
we're fighting for world titles.
What are you do it?
What is wrong with you?
Let's fucking go,
let's fuck a Kelly's guys are getting all pumped up.
And he's like,
all right.
Well he had gotten beaten down by Randy before that.
That fight took a lot out of it.
He wasn't the same guy for a long time after that for the most brutal fight I've
ever seen in my life.
That was Amerigo [inaudible] and Don Frye.
I remember that in Cobo Arena in Detroit too big.
It was way too strong.
It was horrifying because Omri had shot on him and
he's walking his feet,
Don fries,
walking his feet up the cage and drop a knee straight down on Baca armories head
when those were legal.
Yup.
And the entire crowd is roaring.
Kobo arenas pack,
they're going nuts.
And all you can hear over the top of everything is,
um,
is,
is armories girlfriend's screaming bloody murder.
Like,
like someone was being slaughtered in front of her,
which they were.
Right.
And then you've got as Valdo Alvarez,
who's an encyclopedia of Brazilian Jujitsu,
amazing guy and Alan Gomes and Alan Go.
As I had been up there all week to help Omri get ready for the fight,
right.
And Alan go,
it shows up the day of the fight,
the night of the fight walks into the locker room and goes,
what's your name?
I'm going to go pat.
And he goes,
here's a camera.
Take fucking pictures.
That's the way Alan taught,
treated me when we first met.
Right.
Wow.
So I'm watching Omri get mall just completely slaughtered and these guys won't
throw in the towel.
And I'm going,
you got to throw in like,
yeah,
you can say this,
this is stupid.
This is stupid.
And John had stopped the fight.
Mccarthy pull him over and he'd go,
do you want to continue all I'm renewing.
English was more more.
And he's like,
all right,
we're going again.
And he'd get slaughtered some more,
pulling back off,
more,
more sending it back out.
And finally John's like,
I got this.
We're going to have a fatality or the seasons.
So that was horrifying fight.
That was the most brutal fight I've ever seen.
Yeah,
there's been a few of those over the years.
It's been a few of those.
Well listen pat,
we just did three hours,
three hours plus.
Holy Cow.
Time flies by man.
I'm glad we finally did this.
I'm surprised my attention span lasts.
He would teach his feds on point,
man.
It's all that ultra marathon runner.
Right,
right.
We got to do this again man.
I looked at it.
Please everybody check out the conspiracy farm.
Is it on iTunes?
On everything?
Uh,
yeah.
And uh,
if they go to a chemical free body.com you would love that stuff.
Okay.
Chemical Free,
body.com it's all Vegan products,
sprouted Greens,
all kinds of,
I mean the guys go your company or a good friend of mine,
Tim James,
who's saving people's lives from cancer to all kinds of shit.
He is healing people,
veterans with all kinds of open wounds from chemical stuff and Oh,
you say that you do in line fight commentary.
A lion fight.
We no longer cover them.
We cover ces,
ces,
and LFA.
Yeah,
you're in town for that,
right?
What is the,
the event,
is it on an access access TV?
Friday night?
Yeah.
Mark Cuban's network.
We're going to have a blast.
Going to be great fights,
title fights.
There's,
there's some,
uh,
some great fights.
Beautiful.
All right,
pat notes.
It's ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it,
man.
It was awesome.